um
[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys it's friday
everybody everybody's jacked about this
topic this is going to be interesting
topic
topic of a [ __ ] bully gets killed by
the town
this is kind of one of those
actually this is maybe the platonic
ideal of the 13 o'clock episode because
it's a true crime topic which is my
favorite but it's also a true crime
topic where i don't have to feel bad
about the victim because he was a douche
canoe
so you know you know what i mean
so it's like so it's like win-win
um you know but it does kind of bring up
you know
it brings up a lot of discussion about
vigilante justice and stuff like that
which just for the record i'm not
generally in favor of that but
in this dude's case
i might make an exception just this [ __ ]
happens a lot it happens a lot uh more
than people know
um most of it's just dope boys [ __ ]
who sell dope [ __ ] somebody shoots
one of them nobody gives a [ __ ] because
nobody likes that dude anyway
then it goes unsolved for a few years
and then somebody who knew about it ends
up in jail he goes oh if you let me go
i'll give you i'll give you a murder
from two years ago you know he said he
rats out and that's how they usually
solve the case anyway but in in the case
of this one
the town's stuck together nobody ever
spilled the beans i'm sure they know
they kept that [ __ ] those lips zipped
people all this time
this happened back in 1981 and no one
has made a single peep yeah and we got
jenny sitting up here today with her
[ __ ] boob window proudly displayed
and in the comment section we got sandra
and she she's got her birthday birthday
happy birthday
she says she's got a glittery birthday
tube top
i'm gonna have to get a picture of this
uh
you have to post that [ __ ] up on your
only fans page your skinny fat
ass with that [ __ ] glittery ass tube
top
i'm just picturing a glittery tube too
yeah
for some reason it's red with peanut
butter in her mouth
like a spoon yeah
peanut butter and [ __ ] with a peanut
butter cake you've thought a great deal
about this yeah you should have made a
peanut butter cake or a peanut butter
pie or something you said german peanut
butter porn
you heard
that oh yeah they got that going on oh
i'm sure that's a thing yeah it's like
roll 34. yeah german peanut butter porn
it's like a
peanut butter is it is is is is like an
exotic substance in germany so they have
to fetishize it
okay
sorry i just now i just thought of a of
a person
completely covered in peanut butter but
then with a red glittery tube top on top
of that
yeah that edible glitter
yeah okay yeah yeah they do have that
edible juice edible glitter
popular at the gay clubs
just ask zach
he's eating 10 pounds of [ __ ] gay
glitter
yeah the whole inside of his stomach is
yeah your stomach lining is like all
glittery and fabulous i thought i saw
his name just a second ago yeah
roll around on the club floor and all
that damn glitter
glitter and baby oil
man
glitter yeah edible glitter don't people
call glitter like the herpes of the art
world because or the craft world because
it gets everywhere and you can't get rid
of it
well because um i might have told this
story before but um when i was a little
kid
and uh i was living in my grandpa's
house when my uncle was still living
there like when he was still young and
he had made this really kick-ass
halloween mask it was a dragon and he
had made it in its bit it was a big it
was like a full like bot like down to
here
and he made it out of paper mache and
then he covered the whole thing with
like glitter like green and red and
everything like that and that thing was
like it was so scary that when i was
little i was like i wouldn't even go
upstairs because of it but
for
literally 20 or 30 years after that we
were still finding glitter like stuck on
the floorboards and stuff [ __ ] got
everywhere yeah everywhere so uh today
sandra is 52.
really yeah he's 52 today wow
i've decided
[Laughter]
oh you just made that of course i don't
know how old she is
she doesn't talk to me on on facebook
she's talking to esther on facebook
zack says he's never [ __ ] had you
that glitter on a [ __ ]
you know
sandra says that the peanut butter porn
would be like two girls one cup
two girls one cup was faked did you know
that it wasn't real yeah it's still
gross though yeah it looked like
yeah it evidently was fake it's still
gross
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't [ __ ] they
were eating it was something else i mean
if you if you want to see the real [ __ ]
i'm sure it's out there because
everything is but yeah i don't know
there's a bunch of ways they can fake it
dj maniac says zach flirts with him on
facebook
dj maniac said zach flirts with yeah
zach likes to talk man he you know he's
like tom but how's your progress going
yeah send me some muscle shots mark said
that two girls one cup was not fake
because i saw that stuff come out of her
butt yeah but i heard that it wasn't
that they shut they shot something up in
there first it was it wasn't it wasn't
[ __ ] okay but that's still it might as
well be [ __ ] because it's been up in
your butthole them girls have been
[ __ ] crapping out looking whipped
cream forever and eating
something like pudding or something
sorry still gross still gross yeah i
don't want to eat anything that's come
out of something else
that's that's just in general i don't
care that's what i heard i heard it i
heard it got debunked
that's not what they were eating
hey you know what i mean they're into
all that damn anal anal stuff man we
need to get off of the damn subject yeah
how did we get how did we get that
started
[Laughter]
audience knows how to [ __ ] push my
buttons to push me down these [ __ ]
[ __ ] side tracks that are [ __ ]
nasty and [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm willing to
go there i'm willing to go where no man
has gone before oh everybody everyone's
been on there before star trek yeah
we've all gone okay everybody knows
[Laughter]
yeah i was gonna say something that made
me laugh about this case that we're
gonna be talking about
is that um i think it was beowulf up
there that said that they were surprised
that no one had [ __ ] up uh this dude's
gravestone
and honestly i wrote about this case in
one of my books and stuff like that and
i had actually never seen a picture of
his gravestone gravestone until today
because i looked for a picture to like
to put up on instagram
and his gravestone
legitimately says it has his name on it
ken rex mcelroy
uh above his name it says beloved ken
and i was like beloved by who nobody and
also like underneath that it says y'all
are gonna laugh i laughed lap when i saw
this
brave fearless and compassionate
i don't know who paid for that
gravestone um but i'm pretty sure that
they did not know this family members
that disagreed family members
they wanted to protect his reputation
they didn't agree with what people said
you know i wasn't there we just we just
had the story as it was given to us
i kind of feel like though um
if a whole entire town
just wants to put you down like a rabid
dog
then maybe maybe
um allegedly
you're a giant gaping [ __ ] just well
you know they're not gonna put that on a
gravestone
although how funny would that be
here lies my brother dude was a dick
[Laughter]
what a [ __ ] jackal
that's what somebody put a [ __ ] up on
this grape that's what they put on there
in the eight in the 1800s in a while on
a wild west gravestone would be
something like that see i kind of feel
like that would be awesome yeah if
peop if that tradition would come back
again
here lies here here lies to gun mcdillon
he
he deserved and he deserved every bit of
it some [ __ ] like that that's what that
would be suffer [ __ ] yeah he deserved
everything
you know i mean his time ran out i get
that mostly it's family members who
presumably loved this person uh paying
for the gravestone and there's probably
some social pressure involved too but
how [ __ ] funny would it be if there
was just this irredeemable
[ __ ] bag um who everybody hated even his
entire family and then when he died it's
like everybody just agreed that on his
gravestone will just be like you know
r.i.p whatever his name was [ __ ] face
you know what i mean or just like
something like that that would be so so
funny please somebody tell me
there has to be in this wide wide world
of ours
there has to be something like that
where some family just all got together
and said we hated this person because i
kind of feel like
particularly in the west i feel like
there's kind of a thing where oh after a
person's dead you're not really supposed
to say anything bad about them because
they can't defend themselves and stuff
and i'm just like well
i don't know to a large extent that's
true and like i said even as bad as
some people are they still have at least
one person maybe somewhere that loves
them so
but i don't know i kind of have a thing
too where it's just kind of like if you
suck enough
i just kind of feel like no one should
feel obligated to
talk nice about you even after you're
dead
you know got a super chat thank you tb
triggers i'll pay for the tombstone if
tom does that for his
dude had it coming
the thing is though is that you know
in the american old west what also known
as the wild west
in the towns it was for the most part
pretty safe in most of the towns there
was a couple towns that had a real bad
reputation but they weren't there for
very long
it was still the victorian era
and the victorian era
they kind of had a very dark sense of
they had a very dark sensibility when it
came to
funerals you know what i mean they
didn't shy away from death imagery
skulls on stuff yeah why do you think
goths love victorian [ __ ] so much and
cause that shit's morbid yeah they were
like they're like this [ __ ] is dead
down in the god damn grand dead
you know they were like that
uh but the old west was uh it had a
certain amount of practicality and it
was mostly young guys so
the worst thing that could ever happen
to uc like out west
was to not be buried
you just killed and left on a field you
know the animals so the crows at each
other freeze the second worst thing
would just be buried in an unmarked
grave which a lot of outlaws were buried
in unmarked graves [ __ ] those dudes
because no one would care yeah but some
guys were buried in
proper christian burial and evidently
there was it was kind of they do they
they would mostly just put passages from
some poem books or something that
something from the bible
and
maybe like a little quip you know about
him something about him
but it wouldn't surprise me if they um
if he found badasses that came from
money and his friends from his team
buried him and said something you know
i'd have to look up looking sideways
i like snarky yeah
i'd have to i'd have to dig into it
victor getting into it with yet another
eddie izzard reference wherever he falls
there shall he be buried yes i see that
i seem to remember
i seem to remember that in some of those
towns
there was some sideways [ __ ] written on
graves of [ __ ] guys who got killed
fighting over a down poker game or that
kind of stuff they'd say some [ __ ] on
there couldn't accept the loss that got
you know that kind of little quip you
know couldn't accept a lot a little bit
of shade
[Laughter]
lost that money and [ __ ] was wasabi
was got shot over it [ __ ] he wanted
you know he didn't think he lost you
know
not a great card counter that kind of
stuff
you know
for [ __ ] like yeah he had another card
up his sleeve
him going to jesus and [ __ ] you know
it'd be something like that
see i kind of feel like
i kind of feel like that needs to come
back people need to have a little bit
more of a sense of humor about stuff
yeah like i said especially when it
wasn't a nice person you know what i
mean thank you victor you made my day 13
minutes into the show
you always get so excited when i
recognize eddie azzard references yeah
uh saunders says i saw a picture of a
gravestone not sure if it was real that
said something like beloved father
husband and adulterer
yeah they probably do some [ __ ] like
that
that's what yeah like you know what i
mean if you found out like after your
husband croaked yeah he was that he had
been [ __ ] around on you i would
totally do something like that because
that's the kind of [ __ ] i am but uh
yeah i could see i could see a
pissed-off woman doing that
so you know that that's probably real
esther said i want gargoyles and a
horned hand on my tombstone we see back
in the olden days you know it's hard to
tell who was married to who
you couldn't get a divorce so a lot of
guys just move away
and if you move to another state
yeah if you just moved to another state
you could marry all the people you
wanted they didn't know well yeah some
people like serial killers like hh homes
and people like that married all kinds
of [ __ ] all the time yeah
uh this [ __ ] that we're talking
about today
uh married i think he had three wives
not necessarily at the same time i think
a couple of them overlapped except the
thing about it is that
uh at least one or two of them were
children were underage so
i mean that wasn't the only shitty thing
about him like there was it's a long
list but he was also kind of like a pedo
so you know yeah there was that okay
is there any shout outs or anything we
have to do before yeah we got yeah we
got a lot we gotta get into um okay we
did this on the wednesday night show but
maybe we should show it again like i
think i put it over there though
um
michael sent us i don't know if he's
here i haven't seen him in the thing but
michael sent us this kick ass we got
this in the mail the other day like i
said we got it on wednesday i think we
showed it on the show
um because we had just done the hatchet
review
and he had just been at a horror
convention in detroit and had met kane
hotter
and he got this victor crowley figure
and he got kane hodder to sign it to us
so if you guys did not see that
on wednesday there it is it is [ __ ]
epic
look he has little extra hands that's
like that's super cool but yeah that's
like super cool so thank you very much
for that michael he's gonna have a
closer look at that
also wanted to give a shout out to james
who had been one of our patrons but he
actually went annual which you can do i
know that sounds dirty when i say that
but you can do instead of doing monthly
you can go
uh you can pay annually you know what i
mean that was something they started not
too long ago uh so james just did that
recently also uh dermot who is here
sent me an amazon gift card today so
thank you very much for that
um you know he was uh saying if you want
to buy uh where the wind blows which was
the animated
nuclear holocaust movie we were talking
about on wednesday um then you can buy
that or you can buy something else with
it if you want to um like i said i do
actually want to review that movie
sometime soon because that was one that
i just heard about when i was doing
threads and i hadn't like heard of it
is there an address for me to get in on
this oh what's maybe yeah victor said i
missed wednesday yeah i thought you
weren't here i thought you weren't here
karen said i saw a tombstone that said i
told you i was sick yeah i kind of feel
like um you know the haunted mansion at
uh you know disneyland and the one at
disney world they have tombstones that
say that and i feel like that
is kind of like a joke that goes back a
while because i'm pretty sure there are
some real tombstones that said that
um you know because it's kind of like a
it's like a pretty like old joke i guess
but yeah so there's uh that whole thing
so um
what are we talking about now
derek says you're very welcome that will
again thank you very much
oh tammy was saying
victor you me and jenny are gonna have
to get together and go see eddie live i
would actually really like to i never
got to see eddie izzard live and i
[ __ ] love him he's amazing i don't
know exactly what camp guy's talking
about is there an address for me to get
in i think that maybe i don't know maybe
we're i'm afraid i'm afraid to try to
log in or out of anything involved with
youtube you have to be a little more
clear than that camp guy we don't really
know what you're talking about esther
said will there be a jenny birthday show
maybe
i mean wait a minute what day of the
week is my birthday on this year i think
it's on a sunday
so we do usually stream that day so
maybe we'll do something exciting
because it's usually like a matinee
movie review day
of course that's my birthday weekend so
i might be super hungover
but i don't know it might be fun i i'm
pretty sure my birthday's on a sunday
this year i don't know i'll have to look
i haven't even like thought about it
but you know that's why i was like one
of the reasons why i was really excited
that
that it was a september because it's all
my birthday month and that means
halloween is getting close and all the
halloween stuff is in stores
it's still hot as balls here in florida
but
not too bad actually yesterday
we had a really weird
there was like a really weird period of
like an hour or two that where like the
breeze was like actually kind of cool
yeah and we were just kind of like what
the [ __ ] is this about
they're saying hopefully you'll get
through this one
unlike last week you didn't get to get
through the show we got through the show
we always get through the show
it just depends on how coherent we are
this is a lot this is a lot of a lot
smaller topic jenny has a kind of a
strange habit of biting off a lot of
subject material
on something in there like
you look at the notes and it's like six
seven hours worth of notes so you just
can't get through it all
you know what i mean but i've seen i've
already seen what she has she we'll be
able to get through this at least this
is a case that like i said i wrote about
it in my book i'm pretty familiar with
it um
and you know it's funny because
even earlier today i was like reading
through the case and i'm like maybe this
case isn't long enough maybe i should
add another one that's kind of similar
but then i was like no i better not no
yeah i can see it i know how long it
that lasts that's almost three hours
two and a half or three hours well just
because all the and like i said it's you
know the facts of the case there's a lot
of background to it um you know there's
a lot of discussions we can have about
about it um you know i mean there's like
[ __ ] tons of stuff there was like a book
written about this that was called um in
broad daylight i think sundance tv
did a six-part mini-series about this
case
that was called
uh no one saw a thing
um you know and a bunch of other true
crime like i said i think buzzfeed
unsolved did this a couple other true
crime channels uh talked about this as
well so this is a case that's really
because it's still considered an
unsolved murder case right because the
dude
got killed spoiler alert and uh you know
they don't know who did it because no
one's talking so you know
which
i don't really know like you said this
kind of happens
among criminals
a lot
uh you know where even if people if
somebody that you know
is a criminal or like everybody kind of
knows about it that gets kind of shot
down and no one wants to talk to the
cops
which you know i feel like that's kind
of common but this one is kind of a
little bit different because this was
like
i don't want to say it was the whole
town because it wasn't but
i mean this is a pretty [ __ ] small
town and it's even smaller nowadays i
saw a youtube video of a true crime guy
who went there in skidmore missouri by
the way
and he went there in late 2020
and there are less than 300 people
living there i mean it is a [ __ ] hole
it's like two paved roads
and
it looked like pretty much everything
was abandoned like i guess people still
lived there and stuff and there was like
a gas station but everything looked
closed well towns are temporary yeah
especially out in the country
people don't realize it
you go through mississippi and you'll
find towns that are just
the downtown area is just a few empty
buildings built in the 50s or 60s and
all the houses have been torn down
there's nothing there
but a long time ago the town was
relevant because the way the roads used
to go back then and where
businesses used to be but that's all
gone now
i mean though even like this particular
town even when this [ __ ] went down back
in 1981
um there were less than 500 people
living in this town so it was oh so it
was like a dinky tiny little town that
everybody knew everybody yeah even back
then which in a way was kind of how this
dude could just like run roughshod
over everybody yeah just because he was
such a giant [ __ ] and didn't eat
again
missouri missouri okay and didn't have
any compunction about
um you know threatening people shooting
people um you know threatening cops it's
like he just thought he could do
whatever the [ __ ] he wanted we did for a
while and he did for a long time and you
know no one could do anything about it
so like i said in a way like i'm not a
big fan of like vigilante justice but in
this
case
i kind of feel like
go towns folk yeah honestly this dude
was like such a [ __ ] [ __ ] bird
you couldn't do that in mississippi
heidelberger is about that size
yeah my dad's from you couldn't do that
there
i don't know if you could do it now i
don't know if you could do it in the 80s
but you couldn't do that in the 80s in
mississippi
and nothing dramatic would happen you
would just vanish
that's what would really happen
i mean they probably never like feed you
to the alligator they'd never find you
that's what i would do yeah and it
wouldn't be dramatic
they would just know where you walk
where you go and then you know somebody
would know what your routine was they
get up in the bushes with a 22 rifle and
wait for you to pass and pop you in your
head you don't you can't hear those are
very far then you drag the dude away put
him in the trunk just dump him somewhere
they'll never find like i said dumb in a
swamp yeah alligator you don't even have
to be that creative if you're out in
mississippi you do it on the side of the
road that
the next day the animal's gonna get them
because there there are roads where a
car goes down at maybe once a week yeah
you know what i mean
and if you if you're not talking about
a hot teenage girl they're not gonna be
looking for the dude
true it has to be a high value person
if it's a low value person well it has
to be somebody that people are looking
for that people actually kind of care
about they care about kids and and young
attractive women that's what they care
about that's re the grown men they don't
give a [ __ ]
the family man maybe especially
well like i said it depends on because
um there have been a lot of like kind of
unsolved murder case like i wrote about
a bunch of disappearances and stuff of
like
you know 18 to 25 year old but that had
you know families and [ __ ] like that
yeah they were looking for them you know
and family men that had wives and kids
and stuff obviously but like i said it's
more
you know do you have anybody that cares
about you yeah and knows your
whereabouts and that is kind of like
it's kind of sad and we've kind of
talked about this on
some cases especially where you know
serial killers whose victims are largely
like sex workers um some of those young
women um
you know maybe their families do care
about them but their families don't know
where they are
because they've just kind of like
vanished off the or they ran away or
something like that yeah they're not sex
workers per se they're more like bumps
they just happen to do they're in the
sex trade to [ __ ] get drugs but
they're really just living on streets a
lot of them are kind of like bombs
you know a real sex worker is working up
in vegas
she's got a [ __ ] ton of money you know
like and so it's not quite the same
situation he's not killing him because
they're sex workers per se he's killed
him because he has access to him
well yeah that's well that's exactly why
and they're both so when they go
vanishing nobody thinks anything because
they just think they moved away
and that's what happens with a lot of
men
well that's what i mean because man
never comes back and the the cops are
like well he must have skipped town
well if people i mean if a certain you
know demographic of people
are kind of known for just taking off
yeah um you know whether it's sex
workers whether it's you know grown men
without any attachments yeah then no
one's necessarily going to be like
monitoring their movements and wondering
where they went yeah the reason why they
don't look for them a lot of times is
because they don't suspect murder they
just think the dude [ __ ] left yeah
exactly exactly and they just don't know
where to start even looking for the
person yeah it's not quite the same
situation yeah now you know 16 year old
girl comes up missing they think well
maybe she's at her friend's house she
ran off with a guy the family's [ __ ]
worried now where is she they look for
and then three or four days later the
cops are like yeah sonny must have
nabbed her yeah but then they're
searching for a body at that point
yeah sadly most of the time after 48
hours a lot of times they don't even
know where to look they don't know where
to start looking they just wait till she
turns up
which a lot of times they eventually do
well
you know like i said and we've talked
about a lot of the serial killer kind of
cases on here too where
if you have a serial killer who for
example is a truck driver or somebody
that travels along and you know just
picks up random
girls
just walking home from school or walking
or hanging out somewhere and just picks
them up and then dumps them somewhere
else it's like there's really there's no
connection between
uh you know perpetrator and victim
there's no connection between the
location where the body was found and
the location where the person went
missing so it's much much harder to
solve that [ __ ] and sometimes it takes
like years and years and years it's
gotten better now that they have like
dna and they have like a nationwide
database and stuff but
it's still a [ __ ] if you don't really
know where to start looking
you know xanada said i would fake my
death in skiptown for sure
yeah well i know a lot of people won
people have done it especially if they
owe money or if they have a wife they're
trying to get rid of
yeah i mean if they get into a situation
where you know they they think there's
no other way out of it and they're just
like i'm just gonna [ __ ] doop i'm
gonna disappear yeah it's happened i
mean you know harder to do nowadays
right um i kind of feel like that
everything's electronic now and you
can't start it it's easy it's hard to
start a new identity and stuff i mean
you need to like start stashing some
cash away because that's one of the
first things you're gonna do if you go
missing is like check your [ __ ]
credit card and atm yeah you can't use
any of that they'll be able to track you
that's what i'm saying you need to have
like cash money yeah victor says here in
texas they'll feed you to the
chupacabras
[Laughter]
and then sandra says uh you had to take
him out talking about ken miguel mcelroy
sorry yeah uh he was like a dog with
rabies yeah and actually um
he has been compared to that i think one
of the townsfolk also compared him to
a gangrenous leg damn that you had to
like cut off it's funny that he he he um
lived as long as he did doing what he
was they were actually very tolerant of
him
that's what i'm saying i kind of feel
like for a time i get they were afraid
of him i get that he wasn't like perhaps
up in their grill 24 7. um he was just
like a kind of like a nuisance but then
it got worse and worse and worse until
he was like just intimidating people and
then i mean i guess they let him get
away with [ __ ] for a really long time
and finally they just [ __ ] had it
they just had it yeah um and and it was
mostly because the legal system was not
really i mean he had a lot of kind of
outs and he had a lot of a thing that he
would do like he had a lawyer
from kansas city that he said was like a
lawyer for the mob i don't know if
that's true or not
but was really good at getting him off
on charges and he would do the whole
intimidating jurors type of thing
intimidating witnesses type of thing and
everyone was scared of him
so he ended up getting you know even
though he was indicted for like [ __ ]
tons of stuff he hardly ever got
convicted and
it you know and that was bad enough but
he also kind of like went around
bragging about it like essentially i can
do whatever i want to and no one's going
to do anything about it because for a
long time nobody did do anything about
it
that's amazing that he went on that long
we haven't heard the story i know the
basics of it i just think it's amazing
that he he was able to do pull this off
as long as he
he did
just knowing
what little towns are like especially
mississippi
louisiana alabama you could never get
away with this i mean i kind of feel
like you'd think that one enterprising
person would have just like broken into
his house and just like [ __ ]
smothered in him asleep or something
i mean
i don't know anything but i've just
heard rumors of what what has happened
to just poachers
and i can't imagine dude like if y'all
if you guys don't know what a poacher is
it's somebody who hunts illegally
and they do bad [ __ ] like take [ __ ]
heavy fishing line and tie it to a limb
and then take a big trouble a large
treble hook which is a three-sided fish
hook and put that into like an apple so
it's hanging through an apple and a deer
walks up into it and gets hung up in it
and then they just go up and bash the
deer to death with a they check it later
on and they bash it deer to death with a
baseball bat
i mean i just heard
you know heard rumors
yeah that's [ __ ] up
what has happened to dudes that did that
because they're doing that on other
people's posted property
and a hunter will see that deer hanging
from that hook
and he's got two choices he could either
get
let let the let the deer go call the
game wardens
which that's going to be a big [ __ ]
mess or they could just wait for the
[ __ ] poachers to show up and take
care of it yourself
oops yeah oops
didn't see you standing there i was
shooting at a deer here
[Laughter]
so
yeah what are you gonna do i've heard
option three is what happens a lot
oh i can see that yeah i can see that
because if you if
they do it over and over and over again
so how many times have they done that to
deer right get out of it and that's
[ __ ] up yeah that's not hunting no
so yeah so in a way it's kind of like
like i said i'm not a big fan of like
vigilante just some predator [ __ ] from
but sometimes
you hear of somebody doing something
like in a particular i'm like you know
what if somebody just likes you know
quietly just like popped that dude one
and just like was like i don't know
i just i was shooting at the deer like i
said i know no one would cry about it
yeah evidently that's kind of what has
happened over the years
you know yeah according to
just you know things that hunters say
you know that stuff like that does
happen i don't know anything specific
but
that's what they said they would do
if
i'm sure it's happened at least once at
least once yeah i mean you would think
if you were mad enough and you were
standing there you're like man i could
get away with this [ __ ] like right now i
could just if i get caught i'd just say
it was an accident yeah
you know well that nothing's gonna be
sad though that's what i might well yeah
well that's what i'm saying but that's
that's what i mean it's like if somebody
says something like it just say hey it
was an accident no no one's gonna say
anything
mandy says uh interesting topic today i
actually don't know anything about this
one oh you're in for a treat this is a
this is an interesting uh case
uh karen also said he was a big dude
wasn't he yeah it's like i've heard
it's weird because i kind of feel like a
lot of the sources said that he was like
a real big dude like he was six foot
three like 270 pounds like he's a big
[ __ ] dude but then some other sources
said that he wasn't quite that big and
maybe over time like his legend kind of
grew because i kind of feel like he was
almost
i don't want to say he was like a
mythical boogeyman but he was actually
kind of like he did such horrible [ __ ]
and he got away with [ __ ] for so long it
almost seemed like he was like a
mythical being of some kind because he
just kept he would go around like he was
super arrogant too and he would just go
around being like man i can like [ __ ]
kill people and you know they'll never
convic convict me blah blah and then it
seemed like that was coming true so
people were like [ __ ] man maybe he has
maybe he is magic i don't you know what
i mean so it's almost kind of like he
had this like urban legend type of [ __ ]
like
around him which kind of like fed into
this legend about him and like what made
him kind of scary and like made people
like be intimidated by him i guess so
there was that whole thing too sounds
like psychological warfare he's doing on
him that's well yeah that's exactly what
it was even though he was um a dumba he
wasn't like super smart or anything um
he was illiterate
you know and uh so i don't think he was
super smart but a lot of people in town
did say he was very cunning
in the way that an animal is
so
he wouldn't have i feel like he was the
type of person that wouldn't like think
about [ __ ] but he would just have
learned through
you know just from being a [ __ ] his
whole entire life he would have learned
to like how to act and like how to
intimidate other
people from personal experience around
towns this size in the united states
especially you know in rural areas in
the south
um this is a rare rare case
most people could never get away with
acting this way not for long
somebody would get you
they're yeah they're very practical
people and they're related to local law
enforcement you know i mean
yeah and if local law enforcement was
like yeah that motherfucker's got to go
and you're talking about
you're talking about a police department
with three dudes on it and two of them
are cousins well i kind of feel like
that was the situation here too right
it's gonna be [ __ ] like that they're
gonna go that fucker's gotta go he's
gonna hurt somebody
and [ __ ] has a way of working itself out
in the united states when it's working
correctly
[ __ ] works itself out kind of like the
battle of athens we got to do a show on
the battle of athens where we do that
well you want me to write that down but
the battle of athens i had to buy it for
some reason i thought i had a whole
[ __ ] packet of pens in this drawer
right here
uh my one pen that i was using dried up
and i looked for my packet of pens and
it's gone
so i had to order a whole new box of
pens battle of athens happened i think
at night 1947 48 athens tennessee
um all the world war ii veterans went to
war with the police and the mayor over a
[ __ ] up election they died
they attacked a police department in a
jail dynamited it um killed some people
and stuff it was a it called out the
national guard a lot of people know
about it it was a it was a damn
battle that happened in a town
and
the veterans
broke into the local armory and stole
all the guns had machine guns and
everything it's a real good story
that's true they had to do it they had
to do it the [ __ ] cops
the cops and the uh the mayor and
everything were total [ __ ] crooks
total crooks
and you know they tried to
run in elections to get them out and
they kept rigging the elections and then
they wouldn't let anybody see the battle
ballot boxes it's a good story we'll
talk about battle of athens
camp guy said if i was going to take
somebody out i would use a crossbow or
other type of archery launcher and a
deer arrow no gunpowder residue on your
hand see no that would matter anyway
esther said i wonder if a police officer
did the deed to this dude uh it could be
although i kind of feel like most of the
cops well i don't even know how many
cops this tiny little town had um i
think they had left town
i suspect i'm not sure if this is true
or not
i suspect that the cops kind of like put
it in everybody's head because we'll get
into this it's like yeah well you know
if he turns up dead
just um give us a heads up on that [ __ ]
and then they left town
so i kind of feel like maybe they maybe
knew what was gonna go down and they
were just kind of like yep washing our
hands up usually someone will take care
of them usually in a southern town this
size is four people all right a
dispatcher does a radio
a day a day deputy and a night deputy
okay and then the sheriff so three cops
and a ditch dispatcher that's usually
what it is
[Laughter]
a day cop and a night cup
well yeah like i said this is a tiny
tiny town
less than 500 people when this happened
yeah the town now is less than 300
people i think the population at least
in 2020 was 260 people i believe
like i said i saw a video of it it is
literally two paved streets and
everything like he can kind of see a
couple houses in the background but like
all the stores and like gas station
stuff all look abandoned and then no one
was driving around no one was walking
around it doesn't look like anyone lives
there i'm sure like people still do but
it doesn't look like it and they're all
on they're all on call so if something
heavy happens the guys who are off duty
like the other two guys [ __ ]
they all take their cop cars home
you know so they spring into action if
anything happens
yeah there's usually only one cop in the
dispatcher and then they might have a
couple of auxiliaries
which are kind of like
part-time cops
back in the days they would have been
considered like the posse
you know
some civilians that are helping the
police because they call them auxiliary
police
and they might only be another two or
three of those and they probably only
get paid when they're when they call
them type of deal
yeah i get it citizens on patrol yes
they're usually not patrolling though
no i know but that's like i was laughing
because that was one of the wasn't that
one of the police academy movies police
academy citizens on patrol somebody
remind me i kind of feel like i almost
or
at least one of my family members like
saw that in the [ __ ] theater
uh all right so you want to talk about
this douchebag let's go ahead and do it
let's talk about this douchebag um so
yeah he was 47 when he died so you know
fairly long younger than me uh honestly
although he looked uh older
in the way
of uh criminals and
people from that
era i guess because like i said this was
81.
so
this [ __ ]
um as i mentioned there was a six part
series on sundance tv called no one saw
a thing which i've heard is very good
about this case
so this
guy was born in 1934 now
he was the 15th
of 16
children
um
born to tony and mabel mcelroy who were
tenant farmers
uh who had moved from they the you know
ozarks kansas [ __ ] like that they'd
finally settled in skidmore missouri
who the [ __ ] came to town skidmore
will never know that was probably like
seriously that's all i can think of is
like somebody's gross underwear
damn is what i'm thinking
the whole time i think every time i see
that
it just reminds me skid more but yeah so
so that's what the town is called but
they finally moved there they had a farm
and had 16 [ __ ] children so you can
imagine
being
broke-ass
having 16 children
and having a farm to run
you can probably imagine that these kids
were not getting the best or most on the
ball parental care just saying
um you know so there was that whole
thing
although i will say that at least this
child i don't know about his siblings
maybe they turned out okay i don't
really you didn't really hear about them
whole town didn't want to kill the rest
of his siblings so i guess they were all
right
but he honestly seemed like a [ __ ]
from a pretty young age gonna say
um he never really learned to read
he was pretty illiterate
uh you know and he had a family he did
yeah that might have been part of the
reason why they didn't take him out
earlier
afraid of repercussions of the family he
had family at the time that this all
went down mm-hmm okay
so there are people he had he had a [ __ ]
ton of siblings so yeah although like i
said i've never really heard anything
talked about like his siblings
so i don't know how
maybe they hated his ass too i don't
really know it wouldn't um it wouldn't
matter just that he wasn't by himself so
take him out and you're kind of hurting
his siblings in a way yeah and you can
see like because it wasn't a situation
where he was just some some random
buckhole that had like moved to the town
right right and came in and started
swinging his [ __ ] tiny dick around he
was kind of from a family from that area
yeah so he was what they would call can
in a way
yeah so
yeah and like i said this is a very very
very so
a little that afforded him a little more
tolerance
even though he was an [ __ ]
yeah they were like what do what will
his you know siblings think
we can't yeah if we take this [ __ ] out
you know oh man his siblings have come
down on us you know what i mean well see
that's why you have to make it look like
an accident right yeah then that's
second that's first degree murder
and uh you know what i mean that's not
really your average style
and you know what i mean now you have to
[ __ ] start plotting and plotting and
planning and i'm honestly surprised more
people if you live in a state where
there's mountains i'm actually surprised
more people don't just like boop just
like push people off a cliff
because you could totally say that was
like an accident right
yeah but you know you're talking about a
rural area they would it's more likely
that
they would want to deal with this in hot
blood not so much cold blood you know
what i mean that he has to do something
to incite something and you were
defending yourself that's that's more of
an ideal
situation for that culture
i get that that's probably what on the
other hand you can't let the perfect be
the enemy of the good yeah
you know what i mean yeah if there's
[ __ ] country morality involved yeah i
get that i get that so it has to be
something done in hot blood
that's what they're doing yeah no i'm
seeing it right okay sheila ann points
out didn't he have some kind of uh head
injury as a kid yeah later on and this
is kind of something we brought up a lot
on the serial killer shows too because
this is not not all serial killers not
all psychopaths or whatever have head
injuries but a lot of them do
um and
we're not entirely sure
one of the stories he told i think he
told the story of that he had what did
he like he fell off a swing or something
like that
or off a hay wagon or something and it
like busted his head open
uh but then there were also conflicting
reports
that he had been working on a
construction site and like a
like a steel or a concrete thing like
fell on his head and kind of like busted
his head like when he was younger
so did he have any time in a coma or
anything i don't know um i'm not
entirely sure about that because like i
said this is not like super confirmed
but there a lot of sources did kind of
say that he did have a head injury of
some kind when he was younger he sounds
like a kind of guy that maybe had
repeated mild head injuries which that
can that can accumulate
and that is uh you know positively
correlated
fighting all the time with yeah with
lack of impulse control um you know
aggression you know failure to control
your actions that kind of [ __ ] so that
definitely yeah that definitely could be
um a factor sure
yeah it sounds like a guy just got a lot
of fist fights had his head bane's his
brains rattled
makes you meaner and meaner
and if you don't give it any time to
heal up and it could take a long time
then yeah you can get worse and esther
asked if he was abused as a child i
don't know i don't um
not that he ever said not that anyone
not that any source i saw ever said
um
i'm just i'm
extrapolating that just because his
parents were so poor and because they
worked on a farm and because they had so
many children
um you know and he was like the the
penultimate the second to last one uh
that it might have been a case of just
like they didn't really give a [ __ ]
or they neglected him i don't know if
that's true but i'm just assuming
most
heavily rural
kind of southernesque
country upbringings
are not violent most of them are very
chilled
a lot of [ __ ] not a lot of work um it
depends on the situation working around
the house they got [ __ ] garden out
back eating watermelon a lot of fun
usually
um they tend to be very chilled out
so i wouldn't really
if you have a big family like that
it's more likely that
he was kind of a spoiled brat he could
do whatever he wanted he was not or he
was just not supervised
yeah he could just like run go out in
the woods and [ __ ] you're constantly
just kind of like feral no structure no
discipline that's probably what it was
i'm kind of leaning more toward that
probably being the case yeah and then
you know you get into fights you slowly
just kind of evolve into a damn country
badass what they're talking about is
merle dixon
essentially remember merle dixon
yeah a situation like that
except many times worse yeah
i kind of liked borrow
yeah merle was actually deep down was it
was an okay dude yeah this dude came
from a rock i kind of feel like deep
down he was still
an [ __ ] you know what i mean i don't
think there was any redeeming kind of
[ __ ] down in there anywhere
so yeah so as i said uh he did very
badly in school not a surprise he
dropped out of school when he was 15. uh
he had already started doing like petty
crimes and [ __ ] like that by the time he
was 13 so the cops were already well
aware of like this little troublemaker
even when he was a little kid so he
drops out in the eighth grade
and uh goes into a life of petty crime
right as as you do like i said he
couldn't really read and uh you know had
a had a real bad reputation around town
now he started out with kind of petty
[ __ ] you know
thievery arson
[ __ ] like that
um but as usually happens in these
situations as time went on he got more
and more violent uh and it ended up
that he had
like 21 different indictments for
different things
uh this was like assault you know to
getting into fights what not uh child
molestation that was another big one
statutory rape uh actual rape how old
was he when he was doing this um just
from the ages to like 15 into his like
20s he started out doing that [ __ ] well
he started doing petty [ __ ] when he was
13. yeah um but it kind of just went on
so he's not mature and he's not
developing on normal lines he's no he's
basically jungle boy
yeah he's big time
and he has a kind of thing where
i kind of feel like i was watching like
a psych of like a video that was like a
psychological breakdown of him
and he seemed to really have like some
narcissistic personality [ __ ] going on
yeah or you know where he was very
self-aggrandizing he was the best
[ __ ] in the jungle he knew yeah
you know it's not like he's in new york
around a whole bunch of [ __ ] people
that he can compare himself to he's just
the baddest [ __ ] in that in that
town so of course he's in this town of
less than 500 yeah so he's
he's a [ __ ] king on his own pedestal
you know
and he just he really really did have
the um he really did seem to have the
mindset that he could just do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do which in a way
like he could happen yeah it was like a
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah in a lot
of ways he's feral yeah yeah i i kind of
that's a good word i knew dudes like
this he's feral yeah yeah sheila says
why wasn't he in reform school i wonder
that too why would they put in them
i just feel like maybe they didn't give
a [ __ ] back then yeah but this was the
30s and 40s yeah thirties and fours you
talked about in the rural missouri um i
don't really think anybody's like yeah
just [ __ ] whatever just
the whole concept of your
those okay
my dad's side of the family came from
this same type of environment the
mississippi version of it
the concept of government agencies or
anything outside your basically your
little tribe no
[ __ ] no
you don't bring outsiders into your into
your troubles
and the thing is is that a kid like this
out in that rural environment wouldn't
be
seen as that much of a trouble until
like you said late teens early 20s and
by then it's too late well yeah like
once they started getting big enough to
like [ __ ] with other people
and then they're like oh [ __ ] man yeah
should have done something about that
when they were still little enough to
right punish them
and uh you know
it's not like they're gonna send him to
jail jail's just up the street
there's just one room in that little
bitty thing and what are you gonna do
you're gonna send him to prison you know
away from his family and everybody else
and all the town that he knows now
they're not gonna do that
there's you know
well they didn't indict him on some [ __ ]
i mean but i kind of feel like in the
30s and 40s and stuff when he was
growing up yeah i feel like
societally and especially in these
little tiny rural communities
agricultural communities they didn't
really have a good handle on
um you know this person has a
psychological problem and needs to be
seen to or he will hurt himself or
others i kind of feel like that wasn't
really a thing so especially like i said
he was a farm kid he had 15 [ __ ]
siblings um you know his family was poor
and it's just kind of like kids like
that would just like kind of run around
yeah
you know and and no one would really do
much of anything about it like i said
it's a pretty small town so
the impact that he was able to have was
minimized to some extent because the
population was small yeah um
but it just wasn't something that was
bro that was thought of back then i feel
like okay well here's an example
um
my dad's best friends
my dad's best friend
they grew up together
he had a relative who was a cousin who
was around in the family area the whole
family lived on the same block
at that time
and it was these mississippi houses with
[ __ ] farms behind them you know
and today you'd call the kid mentally
challenged he wasn't a kid he was he was
in his late teens when i when i met him
and i was you know
10 or 11.
and
he was kind of like this
not mean-spirited though just totally
out of control nowadays you'd call him
mentally challenged but back in those
days he'd just say he [ __ ]
you know yeah he's [ __ ] and he would
just run around like a wild man and he
would have fun
and uh
get chicks pregnant big old fat chicks
that were kind of like him and um
did [ __ ] weird [ __ ] and [ __ ]
he was like a jethro bodine
okay like a real life jethro bodine
remember from beverly hills billy's just
like that
and you couldn't really keep him out of
trouble but it's not because he was mean
it was just because he could he was
stupid [ __ ] dumb and he didn't know
any better yeah just real real dumb real
super dumb well the thing about this
dude was that he was dumb and mean which
is a really bad combination yeah another
guy i'm talking about wasn't mean but he
was basically feral you know what i mean
he'd walk around without shoes or walk
around without shirts and just think
that was appropriate and just try to go
into
go into a [ __ ] store like that or you
know and this is before walmarts or
anything you know we're talking about
the 70s in the early 80s
and he just couldn't and society was
advancing but he wasn't
yeah and he's evidently still like that
he's an old man now
yeah living on the outskirts of [ __ ]
towns and shacks basically just like
that
i don't have a problem if those people
like don't cause any trouble yeah i'm
kind of trouble but i see where this is
going and i've i can i can i can imagine
what kind of dude this is
the the one that i knew was he wasn't
evil he was funny
i mean but he did some just stupid
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] cut his own [ __ ]
toes off one of the things that he did
whoops by accident at least it wasn't
someone else's toes yeah he's [ __ ]
racing on a damn lawnmower and jumped
off a lawn mower as it was turned upside
down and [ __ ] his leg [ __ ] fell
into the down [ __ ] blades and cut his
toes off
and he hopped around laughing with two
of his toes [ __ ] cut off the big toe
in the middle toe
and um then they had to fix that they
didn't put the toes back on they just
sewed him up
sent them to the hospital yeah i kind of
feel like your toes get off they yeah oh
well they're kind of like well
you're just gonna walk funny yeah
it's not much
walk around [ __ ] um with a [ __ ]
fifth [ __ ] tequila and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you know what i mean and
big drunk
in public [ __ ] the day in the daytime
you know with his [ __ ] 500 pound
girlfriend and uh you know like
she probably wasn't 500 probably about
300 was he happy though oh yeah oh yeah
he was having fun yeah and he'd tell you
all kinds of stories it didn't make any
goddamn sense he's making the [ __ ] up
you know and
couldn't read or write and
you know his his mom had him when she
was you know
in her late 40s and he just came out
like that
he just came out he came out like that
yeah came out a little bit [ __ ] up
yeah a little bit yeah thank you david
june yeah
he gave us money for happy he said happy
birthday to her yeah but like i said you
know to an extent that's true but this
dude was also
a [ __ ] and he knew that he was a
[ __ ] he enjoyed being mean he
enjoyed being a bully he enjoyed picking
on people
and everyone that knew him
said that he was dumb in a sense that he
couldn't read and [ __ ] like that but he
was also like really cunning in the
sense that he knew who was weak and who
he could pick on
and he kind of knew how to get his way
type of thing so he wasn't that stupid
right you know what i'm saying yeah so
he's not exactly like what i'm talking
about yeah but the dude i was talking
about he was he was basically feral
yeah yeah this dude had like half that
but then half just kind of like evil
okay yeah and like i said he really
seems like he had no redeeming qualities
at all yeah even though it's weird
because i've i watched a lot of
documentaries about this
and
a lot of the documentaries
are talking about how he fathered all
these children and stuff like that so
women must have found him charming i'm
like did you not read the part where he
was kind of like a rapist
i was like did these women necessarily
have a lot of choice in the matter and
honestly like a lot of the women that
are women girls that he went after were
like 12
so
how much [ __ ]
like how much [ __ ] consent could they
really give type of thing
um you know we'll get into that in a
second because that's kind of like a big
a big part of like uh what happened to
that [ __ ] i'm gonna make another
drink here yeah i kind of need one too
actually just top it up
uh grantham's hammer says in my
experience most criminals were slightly
lower than average intelligence and most
cops are slightly above average
intelligence which is why we usually won
yeah i do kind of feel like the
the myth of the super intelligent serial
killer maybe that started with hannibal
lecter i'm not entirely sure but um
i kind of feel like people
i know it's a cool it's a cool fictional
story
but
most serial killers are not really all
that bright um the only reason they
don't get caught for a long time in some
cases
is just because
they choose victims that like i said are
vulnerable or aren't being looked for
you know it's [ __ ] like that and uh it's
it's more that than them being smart
that that's all i'm saying because a lot
of them are really not all smart
so
uh so like i said this dude started his
little criminal career uh at least 13.
uh they know that
maybe earlier i don't really know but um
so yeah so he just got like assault like
i said child molestation which came a
little bit later statutory raped again
came a little bit later arson which is
one thing that he started doing when he
was young just burning [ __ ] down
burglary probably one of the first
things that he started uh with also one
of the things that he would do he was
really into stealing
grain uh gasoline like he would you know
steal gasoline out of cars or out of
people's you know barns or whatever um
alcohol he stole antiques uh he was he
was big into that and he was real into
like stealing people's uh hogs and
cattle
and uh so all of these little criminal
activities
ironically or maybe not ironically i'm
not really sure but he actually did make
quite a bit of money from this kind of
[ __ ] like on the on the little uh
criminal circuit there that's king so
okay
oh it smells good ooh it smells like a
pineapple upside down cake i don't know
he just went to the liquor store today i
didn't go because i was too busy
whoo all right
it tastes like an orange cupcake all
right so so he always had like uh big
wads of cash on him uh from all his
little uh criminal activities and all
the little [ __ ] black market [ __ ] he
was doing
now
for all of these charges
uh he actually was indicted
you know he had charges brought against
him
21 times
over
the years you know what it was you know
over like 20 years something like that
but as i mentioned earlier
he was always always
able to avoid conviction
because
usually
witnesses would not testify
because
a big thing that he would do like i said
this is a very small town and if he got
charged with something
and he remembered obviously who he had
done this [ __ ] to
so and he
was gonna go to trial or whatever
he would go to
the witness's house
and he would just sit in front of their
house for sometimes hours at a time
sorry i don't know why i'm coughing all
of a sudden
hours at a time and then he would do it
for like hours that like sometimes he'd
sit there all night in his truck like
out in front of their house sometimes
he'd get out and like shoot into the air
so he would like use all these
intimidation tactics um you know he
would follow them around
[ __ ] like that for like a really long
time
so that people were really reluctant
to
you know testify against him because
they knew that he was just willing to
you know
i hate to say but he really did have a
lot of resolve in the sen in his uh
[ __ ] henry that he would just like sit
in front of people's houses for like
hours weeks at a time
and like
shoot guns in their yard and stuff it
just to like intimidate them into not
testifying against him as i mentioned
earlier he also had because he had a lot
of money from all his little crimes that
he was pulling
um you know he had a lot of cash
he hired this defense attorney named
richard mcfadden who was from missouri
who like i said
ken would always say that he was like oh
you know an attorney for the mob or
whatever but i don't know if he was
but he was whether he was an attorney
for the mob or not he was real good at
getting ken off on [ __ ] and
um i believe
that mcfadden
is perhaps on record as saying that ken
was like his best customer because [ __ ]
was always getting arrested for [ __ ] and
always paid in cash and always paid on
time and he always got off
you know what i mean so
which is kind of a [ __ ] up that's
pretty [ __ ] up
so as i mentioned
uh ken ended up fathering
at least 10 10 children damn with
different women
and as i said i kind of feel like when
documentaries i've watched about this
bring up that fact
they almost
imply that it's like well he must have
been maybe charming to women
i'm like yeah but he was also super
aggressive and
aggro and he was like kind of rapey
so like i said how much [ __ ] choice
and like i said a lot of his wives and
[ __ ] like that he hooked up with them
when they were like [ __ ] 12 or
something like that so it's kind of like
how much
choice did they have in the matter i
don't know i just kind of feel like
maybe he walked around talking [ __ ] and
[ __ ] impressed him
maybe there isn't there is a certain
easy to impress a 12 year old well i
kind of feel like that's why he went
well yeah and it was probably easy to
impress like any kind of teenage girl
that lived in a town this small is as
sad as that is to say oh yeah you know
he's like this big bad
because there is a certain type of girl
especially if you
have daddy issues or if you're uh you
know not real
savvy of the ways of the world or
whatever um this type of dude is very
attractive just always a bad boy but he
loves me you know what i mean
how old was he when when he was doing
this he was in his thirties at the
thirties
yeah
that's weird
well
what year we talk about we're talking
about in the 70s at this point
this is probably around the 60s and 70s
and 70s yeah yeah
you could get away with a lot more back
then especially out in the country
yeah with the way it was
there's nothing to do out there
no internet the 70s there wasn't even
any there wasn't even cable
so you know you're dealing with very
naive people
in a certain ways yeah and i think that
really like fed into this whole
story you have to think it's not like
nowadays you're right another thing is
this you know i remember the 70s and the
80s
visited my dad [ __ ] mississippi
and back in those days
the
the girls just they were cute man real
good looking better than the girls in
california at the time just super cute
they're all gone no though now everybody
moved to cities mtv and cable television
changed the south a lot and the rural
in rural america changed them a lot when
they saw those music videos like oh [ __ ]
it i got to get out of here they left
yeah you know the best ones did
well that i kind of feel like now
particularly nowadays that happens a lot
in like those kind of small towns
because
you know what are you gonna do there
right there's nothing to do there no it
was well they they drank and had sex
well yeah that's that's all you could do
yeah
and that's why because like i said even
nowadays like these little bitty towns
even now that we have the internet and
we have like you know other outlets
but even now it's like when you see
these kind of like um communities have
been like ravaged by oh the youth are
all on meth and stuff like that it's
always these little
towns like this because no one has
anything else to do right there's
nothing to do yeah so it's kind of like
you can't blame the kids jesus christ
they want some entertainment yeah
yeah the whole drug epidemic you know
what i mean that's in a way kind of like
nature taking its course like up in the
rust belt
huge swaths of the population just
becoming decimated because they're just
technologically obsolete there's no they
were they were born to parents that were
working these factory jobs that are not
that have now moved away
to china there's no reason for those
cities to even be there anymore
so rat sets in just like gangrene on a
dying [ __ ] limb of a criminal there's
a thing now where some cities
particularly ones where a lot of people
like younger people have left now that
everyone's kind of going to remote work
um a lot of cities are kind of trying to
get people to move back there so they'll
like give you like a big
uh you know chunk of money like to move
there and like start your business up
like in there yeah or well yeah in like
certain it's usually like
rural like southern community stuff like
that because they're trying to get
people to move back in and like fix the
houses up yeah um you know and you're
doing remote work they'll give you free
office space [ __ ] like that yeah they're
trying to like redo the yeah but that's
that's like fighting an ocean
you know trying to hold back on ocean
this goes back to some of the other
shows i said i've seen the analysis
seen everything that's happened in a
damn market cities are technologically
obsolete because they're centered around
office buildings well i'm not talking
about big cities i'm talking about
little oh little towns yeah i'm talking
about the future that's where the future
will be the
in the future everything will kind of
look suburban it'll all just be spread
out
be spread out because it's just it's
more efficient that way
dermit says they might flock to their
little incel online communities now
right seriously eventually we needed to
do a show about [ __ ] elliot roger and
a whole that kind of yeah that's going
to be good i got a lot to say about that
i put it in the poll like at one time
but it didn't win
like i think it only lost by like one or
two votes though so i'll put it in there
again we'll see how it goes but yeah so
that's funny that they call them in
sales
that's what they called themselves yeah
it's just funny
i've heard of people talking about femme
cells we were talking about fem cells
they got femme cells
but it's just funny how there's a word
for them i remember them in the 90s and
they were just losers online and they
were hilarious
you know
on on they were on those [ __ ] forums
and they post pictures of themselves and
everybody laugh at them like that's
really you you know just they would tell
stories about themselves it's just funny
[ __ ] funny maybe they're masochists
yeah
yeah well there's be like a whole bunch
of them on these forums [ __ ]
talking about what losers they are to
each other
you know and then people trying to
incite them to [ __ ] talk more about
what a loser they are just [ __ ] funny
like i said that sounds like masochism
yeah i remember in the late 90s you know
i'm in their very early internet when
all that was happening yeah and i was
tripping i remember that i was tripping
you know i was like because he it was
kind of exp
uncovering a segment of society i didn't
really know existed but
of course there's going to be guys that
just sit at home
and enter online you know what i mean
and [ __ ] they're on some kind of
disability they can't do anything
they're trying to live a damn social
life through through on early primitive
internet
but they were kind of cool they would
come up with some cool [ __ ] maybe ray
would write some [ __ ] cool [ __ ] if i
could
make some [ __ ] weird things writing
manifestos [ __ ] up with that no they
would just be talking about just you
know just talking about their lives and
stuff they're
wang there's a channel called wang talks
about them a lot they had some famous
ones from the past and just
you know conversations that they would
have with the whole crowd that went on
for years and like photographs that they
would
post and things that they'd start
getting flamed by other users and
certain things that they would do and
what was said it was just like a history
of the early history of the early
internet you know and you'd be following
these guys it was just hilarious
they became kind of like
superstars of the early internet
you know but well yeah before the
internet was like before it was
widespread yeah it was i kind of liked
the old internet
when it was just like a few people on it
you know
he felt like kind of like special like
you're in an underground
i don't i don't i like the internet the
way it is now um i like real life uh
with fewer people in it
because i like to go out and like
everything not be crowded yeah camp guy
said like anthony michael hall and 16
candles honestly though i'm gonna like
nitpick because i don't feel like even
though he was a geek oh he went into
denzel i don't think he was an incel
though because
well there was kind of a thing where he
was kind of like he was a dork but he
knew he was a dork
but he was also kind of confident yeah
and he was like picking on his other two
friends for being in cells dudes like
that actually turned out all right i i
knew guys that were like that in high
school they turned out okay they they
got girlfriend i thought he yeah well
honestly anthony michael hall in that
movie
i'm like he's actually like kind of like
he's kind of dorky but he's also kind of
cute and he's funny yeah and
you know what i mean so i don't know if
i'd call him an intel because he did
actually have like some social skills
grampur's knows exactly what i'm talking
about mike kowalski our friend mike
kowalski was just like that he looked
like that and everything
and he runs a [ __ ] ambulance company
now he's you know [ __ ] big strong guy
[ __ ] good-looking wife much kids you
know he turned out great
that's what i mean and that's why that's
why
you know people that are still like in
[ __ ] high school for crisis yeah
they're just still developing you know
please like if you're in high school i'd
have like probably everybody here is
like older but please if you're in high
school um please don't think that that's
the be-all end-all because honestly i do
not even remember
most of the [ __ ] that happened in high
school it is really not important i know
it seems important at the time i get it
uh you know i was there too but
in the long run you're not even going to
remember most of those people
you're not going to remember most that
[ __ ] that happened it's really not worth
it so just just saying xanada's laughing
because he's a kid in the forums
yeah forums man that's the way it was i
was on the [ __ ] aka kalashnikov form
man and we were [ __ ] doing talking
about nothing but ak-47s and 74s and
they had a dude on there named tantal
who was a guy from a [ __ ] polish
[ __ ] ak factory here that was friends
for him for a long time and uh got some
[ __ ] rare ak parts
and stuff you know they were legal to
import you know they weren't they
weren't like trigger mechanisms they're
like rare magazines and not the whole
magazine just the body it was weird you
know what i mean like a weird bacon
weird
bakelites ak-74 magazines that were
never sold to the public uh
bison [ __ ] magazines which was
i'm getting off into don't worry about
it yeah you were okay yeah he just real
i didn't even say anything i didn't make
a face yeah i'm going i'm going down you
probably thought i made a face but i did
just i'm just trying to get myself in
check because nobody knows what i'm
talking about what a bison is
but uh sometimes he thinks i makes a
fake make a face at him and i'm not
making a face i was just like thinking
about something else and spacing out and
he thinks that i'm like making advice at
him but i'm not making a face yeah
so it was just the old internet was
funny because you can you could talk to
guys who are like famous within like a
certain segment
because some of them were on there and
they weren't being swamped by millions
of people so you could interact with
them well it's still kind of the same
thing nowadays like i said and i kind of
like that everything's kind of like
broken down into like little communities
yeah um you know of people that like
really like certain things
you know i kind of feel like in the
early internet i was my main thing was
you know
mst 3k [ __ ] yeah because i'm a dork
um so that was kind of my main thing
back in the back in the old days of the
interview going on the mst 3k forums
talking about other mstp you know fans
and goth people too because like i said
i grew up in somewhere where there
wasn't really a lot of people that are
into that kind of stuff dave june says
he ran into dave chappelle back on the
old world of warcraft [ __ ]
really yeah that's interesting
uh yeah they're talking about uh
oh afterlife do you guys mean the movie
oh no no the one with um what's his
[ __ ] name they were just talking
about ricky gervais
uh that's actually a really funny movie
if you're into ricky gervais he was on
if you guys don't know he was on the
original office the british one uh and
he's super funny and he's real in uh
big up in like the atheist scene and
everything like that too
um so
yeah he did a movie called afterlife
which is kind of like an atheist
sort of movie but it's like a comedy too
but go ahead and hit the like button
people please hit that like button for
us okay so okay so where was i so
this dude like yeah we got off on in
cells yeah because we're talking about
this dude
fathering 10 children i wonder what
happened to those kids
are they still around and they're like
do i [ __ ] know these they might be
listening
oh i wonder yeah it wouldn't be that old
man
although i kind of feel like the
situation that this probably arose out
of i kind of feel like maybe these kids
were probably born and they like didn't
even know who their dad was or their mom
didn't know because i kind of feel like
he was that type of dude i don't know
so yeah so he had at least 10 kids maybe
more they don't really know
now he was married
married
three times maybe i don't know
the legality of it the overlapping of it
uh is a little bit questionable so i'm
not entirely sure
um he was for sure married to this one
uh girl woman named alice
uh but then he met this other girl
named trina macleod
when she was
12 years old he was i think
35.
he was 35
she was 12. she was in the eighth grade
and he decided this is going to be my
next wife
hmm yeah so
yeah so he uh you know
essentially rapes this 12 year old girl
it's still statutory rape
even if she says okay that's
way underage even in this state even in
missouri even back and then
even back then um
and another thing too and we'll get into
this in a minute
he wanted to marry her so he wouldn't
get arrested for statutory rape
uh her parents understandably said no
yeah like hell no so ken
let me just give a dramatic pause ken
shot the family dog dead
and burned their house down damn
to get
them to consent
to him marrying her so he wouldn't get
into trouble i can't believe he got away
with that one
like i said that would get you killed in
mississippi honestly if that was all he
had done just shooting a dog he still
deserves a killing yeah just shooting a
dog i mean he did a bunch of other [ __ ]
other on top of that but even if it was
just that honestly even just shooting a
dog yeah unless that dog's gonna rip
your throat out
you know okay in that case you get a
pass
if that happened in rural mississippi
you'd be killed
i like it shout out somebody's dog
that's it that's like shooting
somebody's child he was eventually well
like i said i get that i get that yeah
it kill you on the spot and nobody's
even called the cops
chances are don't even see it
because that's how rural it is they
never find you jesus [ __ ] christ yeah
all right so that was how he got
trina's parents to consent to the
marriage
by shooting their dog and burning their
house down
you know that that was how he got
everything by intimidating people
doing this kind of [ __ ]
so uh she got pregnant when she was 14
years old
dropped out of school when she was in
9th grade
and went to now at this point
he hadn't married her he was still
married to his second wife alice
trina who at this point is 14 and
pregnant
moves in with him and alice okay so you
got both of his wives
yeah he's trying to do some like [ __ ]
mormon [ __ ] right
so at this point
uh ken decides well i'm gonna divorce
alice the second wife and marry trina
so i don't get statutory rape charges
because like i said at this point trina
is only 14 years old uh and alice was
also a witness to that [ __ ] so if they
were married it would be cool i guess
uh because it's missouri
it was like the 70s so you know whatever
now
16 days after like seriously trina gives
birth to the kid
the kid is like a little more than two
weeks old
trina
and alice the two wives were like let's
get the [ __ ] out of here which you know
understandable
so trina and alice got the [ __ ] out of
there
so they ended up going that running off
with the baby
thank you david
never heard of this douche canoe thanks
for the enlightenment
he's pushing that far even for the
[ __ ] 70s now if trina was like 14
that probably would have flown in
missouri in the 70s so he's really only
pushing or pushing it by about two years
i think 14 it probably wouldn't have
been a problem
calico 26 points out and i was going to
get into this a little bit but trina
said later that the house burned down by
faulty wiring see
i kind of and this is really sad to me
because i kind of feel like because she
got under his clutches
so early
that
she would like defend him yeah later on
i remember mississippi um even in the
80s up in the late 80s i can remember
like
age of consent was like 14.
all right
you could marry a girl at 13 i think but
you had to have parental consent
and that was the 80s
yeah
and it was now
were they doing that
no
they weren't i hope not no it was very
rare because that was stopped that well
that was stuff that was from the 20s
those laws
that's like from the 20s
and it's just nobody really challenged
them that wasn't an issue
that's one thing it's like a lot of
these kind of laws that are still on the
books it's like you know they're still
on the books because nobody
the situation doesn't come up anymore so
nobody really like challenges it right
sheila is asking how did a 35 year old
meet a 12 year old girl well they're all
hanging out in the same town yeah it's a
it's this is a tiny tiny tiny town
everybody knew each other there's no
there's nothing really to do there yeah
this is pre-internet pre-cable
pre-television some of it no that was
40s i was thinking the other 70s there's
we've been pre-cable
so um entertainment is uh
in person
you know
they don't have electronic entertainment
yes from his point of view this is just
another person in the town she just
looks good he's gonna he's gonna do it
he doesn't he he's not really thinking
about the age the age is a
obstacle he's got to get around
but if she was 14 or 15 or 16 he'd still
be going for it yeah he doesn't care and
he's clearly just trying to get around
like he doesn't care that you know what
i mean she's 14 years old she's like
half his age you're less than half of it
the dealer's dude is kind of
intellectually [ __ ] dumb
so
they're probably the same intelligence
level
i kind of feel like that's the case with
a lot of these dudes that go after these
teenage girls that's more like mentally
their peer yep
that's exactly what it is yeah that's
exactly what it is
so okay so at this point like i said he
divorces alice who was his second wife
um and married trina so he wouldn't get
statutory rape charges because she was
underage
um
so trina gives birth to the kid a couple
weeks after that trina and alice both of
his wives both were like let's get the
[ __ ] out of here so they took off
um you know they escaped so they went to
trina's
mom's house her mom and stepfather's
house so they go there
now
they're there and they're hiding out
kind of
but ken of course kind of feels like he
knew where they went so he tracked them
down there
and essentially like dragged them back
to his uh own house
and then he went back to trina's parents
house again
shot their dog and burned their house
down as well
so like i said
how many times is this the second time i
am
again just one time
i kind of feel like that's enough for
someone to like [ __ ] pop you
two times yeah that that's wonder why
they're not all talking to each other
well some of this i kind of feel like
when they went to um trina's mom's house
that was like the next town over
if i'm remembering correctly so that was
like going to another country
they weren't talking
yeah that was happening in the same time
they'd start colluding against him and
like i said this is kind of you have to
think too this isn't like nowadays where
everybody's like talking to everybody
like online it's like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] doing and probably
didn't know
maybe they didn't know so i kind of feel
like maybe you can't like victim blame
too much because maybe
um even though people talked it was a
small town and stuff but
i do kind of feel like
nowadays this kind of [ __ ] would get
you know identified immediately
back then maybe not so much maybe it
wasn't egregious enough or
frequent enough
um for people to
for him to be like in the forefront of
people's minds all the time you know
what i'm saying
i don't know it's maybe that's why what
grandpa said where is it he's got two of
them i lived in bfe parts of oregon and
north carolina married people cheating
on each other child brides long-running
grudges families versus families very
common yeah you know that's just kind of
what it's like
um
rural folks aren't dumb just aren't very
sophisticated in their thinking about
complicated and nuanced issues yeah i
kind of feel like i would never say like
an entire segment of the population is
stupid but they're just not really
i don't know they don't they just don't
they're everything's very direct well
they're so like wrapped up in their own
daily lives that they're not really
thinking about like the bigger picture i
kind of feel like a lot of times so
they're not really like thinking about a
lot of like bigger issues maybe also
they didn't back in those days it was
difficult to get a context of anything
because there wasn't a social media the
norms were very different you weren't
sure what the norms were
if an unusual situation appeared you
weren't really sure what it was you were
supposed to do about that situation
because it was just the first time you
see you've seen this situation you're
like whoa
what's the what's what's the correct
thing to do how do i how do i [ __ ]
deal with this
you know what i mean so nowadays people
go on social media start talking about
it with a bunch of people they come up
with something
but not back then they couldn't do it
yeah sure what was normal either
i mean like i said in a way i know
people [ __ ] on like the internet and
it's like yeah there's like bad size to
it too but in a lot of ways i kind of
feel like it's kind of an equalizer
um even if you live somewhere in like
some shitty bfe town if you have an
internet connection
at least you have people like that you
can talk to
what about this [ __ ] you also have
access to the world's [ __ ] knowledge
right and they didn't that didn't exist
back then yeah which you yeah you really
do have to remember that
people of this era was easy for them to
get overwhelmed psychologically about
something because
what do i do because that was all that
was going on in their life was this tiny
little town
and everything that was going on
was
i'm kind of glad it's not like that
anymore i mean honestly
so
according to trina
uh ken
gets indicted in june of
on several charges one of which was
arson for burning the houses down
obviously uh assault and statutory rape
like i said against her because she was
under age
so he gets arrested booked he's
arraigned but he gets released on twenty
five hundred dollars
bail
now at this point because he's released
trina and the baby who is only a couple
weeks old two three weeks old
they get put in foster care because she
was still 14 right yeah 14 years old
three week old baby they put her in
foster care in another city like
maryville missouri
but somehow
ken
found out where her foster home was
and
again as he did with many witnesses uh
in his you know uh cases where he was
you know
trying to intimidate witnesses
he found out where the foster home was
where she was staying and he would go
park his truck in front of their house
uh for hours at a time and just sit
there and stare at their house
just very being very intimidating
he also allegedly went up to the foster
family that was keeping his
wife and
child
and i'm putting bunny rabbit ears on
that
um and he said hey
i'll trade you girl for girl
the foster family had a biological
daughter
and ken implied that he knew where she
went to school
and that he was going to kidnap her
and trade her
for his wife and child
so you know special
uh so at this point
the authorities find out about that and
uh you know this is like some [ __ ] you'd
see happen in afghanistan
this dude [ __ ] man
i'm surprised no one's killed him at
this point yeah oh my god
so he gets additional charges piled on
but again nothing is really done about
it
now
a few years go by july 27 1986
uh there's a dude in skidmore who is a
farmer his name is romaine henry romaine
lettuce henry
that's what i'm gonna call them i'm sure
that's romaine lettuce yeah i'm sure
that's what everybody called them i'm
well i'm gonna call him that i love you
dude you're all right
um
now he says i saw actually um
i think he's dead now but i did see like
some interview footage with him from
like
the early 80s or the mid 80s or
something like that
on youtube
now he says
that what happened in july of 1976
was that he had some land
uh ken decides he's going to come on
romaine's land
and
shoot at stuff
romaine's not happy about this
so he goes up in his truck
to ken and be like hey bro knock it off
and then ken shot him twice with a
shotgun
once he put the shotgun against his
stomach
and just shot him right in the face and
again he shot him again and i think it
was like in his face or like part of his
face
uh the dude survived thankfully yeah but
yeah i saw like part of an interview
with him and he was like sitting in his
truck i guess he was sitting in his
truck when it happened because he said
that you know yeah he put the shotgun
like right up here against my stomach
and he just like [ __ ] shot me and it
just went all over the [ __ ] side of
the truck
so
yeah so he shot a dude in the [ __ ]
stomach and in the face
um and it wasn't even this was on
romaine's property he just came out here
and said hey can you like not shoot guns
on my property i would appreciate it and
then ken decides oh well [ __ ] that
i'm just gonna shoot you this
motherfucker's out of control
that's what i mean so that's what i'm
saying why
like i said i'm not a big fan of
vigilante justice but in this case me
i'm not why hasn't he been operating i'm
not saying nobody's reported this guy
yet
i mean they have yeah but they just
haven't arrested but nothing that he's
been arrested he's been charged but he
always gets off like nothing he has a
one he has money so he has like a really
good lawyer
um where's the two coming from
his criminal activities
essentially he has a lot of cash all
right uh and he has kind of like i don't
know if the lawyer was crooked but the
lawyer was kind of like well he always
paid on time and he was a good client so
whatever
um so it was that kind of situation also
like i said he was very good at
intimidating people that were going to
like be witnesses
uh in any of his crimes
you think that was attempted murder it's
hard it's
hard to believe that he [ __ ] was able
to talk himself out of that one just
with some money
on this particular case he did get
charged but he was charged with
assault with intent to kill
yeah
which i don't know what's the difference
between assault with a tent to kill and
an attempted murder because that seems
like the same thing but i don't really
know maybe that's a state law maybe
that's missouri is like something
um so ken
said yeah i wasn't even there
and he actually kind of got two dudes
to say
that
they had been with him at that time so
they give he got two dudes to go like
give him an alibi yeah also during this
whole entire time the dude who had been
shot
said this [ __ ] was sitting
outside my house at least a hundred
times
was sitting outside his house like until
like staring at him right shooting guns
[ __ ] like that he was doing all that
kind of crap
um so what ended up happening though
this did actually go to trial
but what ended up happening was that
the dude that got shot
um
ken's lawyer richard mcfadden
he actually came out and like started
like grilling the victim of this the
dude that had been shot and said well
hey
don't you have some kind of like
criminal conviction from a long time ago
and he did the victim so somehow that
like negated
so some i don't know like i said ken
kept getting off on [ __ ]
uh for various reasons
so he ended up getting off on that too
even though he straight up shot a dude
in the stomach
and in the face
the dude survived but
[ __ ] and ken was on this dude's land
the dude said was like hey don't fire
guns in my land and then the dude's like
man man [ __ ] you and he shot him right
in the stomach missouri must have really
been [ __ ] up in the 70s holy [ __ ]
really [ __ ] up you couldn't get away
with that in mississippi
i think attempted murder even back in
the 70s you're probably looking at 10
years minimum
and i don't think you can intimidate a
witness out of it i mean you know [ __ ]
that's so that's some weird that sounds
like local [ __ ] corruption if you ask
me
there may have been some of that
involved too i'm not entirely sure about
that you might have had dirt on somebody
in the system somewhere which afforded
him some protection somehow
that would make a lot of sense that
makes more sense to be honest with you
because in a normal small town south
heidelberg mississippi as soon as they
focused in on you they'd get you out of
there they either kill you or get you
convicted on something grandparents
[ __ ] back me up he's the ex-cop right
there he ha he must have known somebody
a mayor
or he he did some dirty work for
somebody and they were
protecting him
that's only i can think of
they needed him for some reason
i don't know i don't know if i i don't i
don't know if it went that far up it
just kind of seems like
this dude
it seemed like he was just
too much trouble for people to deal with
because like something that he would do
other than
parking in front of people's houses for
like i said hours weeks at a time
um you know just intimidating what is
this firing guns off in their yard so
you can go outside he would like leave
rattlesnakes in your mailbox he would do
[ __ ] like that he's also saying that
he's a [ __ ] gangster and [ __ ] so he's
involved with somebody somebody in that
town somebody somebody linked in with
the law or the mayor
somehow
he's doing something for him that's
where the money's coming from maybe he's
selling drugs for them or something
and like i mentioned it does seem like
too that sums up with this for a long
time in this small town because this
dude was you know because ken mcelroy
was such a
an [ __ ] and such a pain in the ass
um but because he was very good at
intimidation tactics and because he had
money and he had a really good lawyer
so a lot of times
what would happen is that
if you had something happen to you that
wasn't life-threatening like some of
your cattle disappeared or some of your
gasoline disappeared out of your [ __ ]
you know uh tractor or whatever
you wouldn't necessarily report it
because she's like oh you knew ken was
probably responsible and if you bitched
about it
then he would like do this [ __ ]
terrorist kind of tactics on you and a
lot of people just didn't want to be on
the end of that so it's just like they
would
you know they would just like let it
slide grampner says the south is really
bad for
with criminals having local politicians
on their side the north less so well a
lot of times a lot of times the
politicians in the south were also
criminals they had but um
the north they also had it i mean a lot
of your a lot of your new york officials
for a long time
directly came from organized crime you
know they were
italian criminal families and there was
many different kind of criminal families
that ran new york it was really
new york right now when you look at new
york right now it's just returning to
the way it was
new york was only kind of decent for the
past what 20 30 years before that time
it was a [ __ ] it's gonna go back to
being this [ __ ] too
camp guy said amazing that guy lasted
that long yeah that's what we're talking
about i would take care of that uh asap
me and about five or six others yeah and
eventually they did uh take care of this
dude but like i said i can understand
why maybe maybe
um it didn't like why it took so long it
seems like you're not really
communicating with each other
i kind of feel like that might have been
a factor also
um you know they were worried about
not just themselves but they were
worried about their families their
children they were particularly worried
about their daughters because they knew
like what a [ __ ] pedo this [ __ ]
dude was and they were just kind of like
what if he you know kidnaps our daughter
what if he does this and that so they
were like worried about it i'm just
saying
um so
the thing that led to
ken
let's call him ken getting his
comeuppance
was a very uh you know in context was a
pretty minor issue
so this was in april of 1980
um
what ended up happening was that
sources differ either one or two
of trina and ken's daughters
were in
uh like a
general store in town
uh one of them was four
and the other daughter i think was 14.
so they're in this general store in
skidmore missouri
owned by a dude
like an older dude named bo bowen camp
now
apparently what ended up happening and
like i said i've heard
many different variations of this
but the gist of the story is that
perhaps the four-year-old who's only
four years old she was a four-year-old
girl
maybe
took some candy from the general store
it was like trying to steal her like
didn't pay for it
now
some accusations say that like well
she didn't pay for it she tried to leave
and then the store clerks like
confronted her about it
the store clerks and the people that you
know the family that owned the store
were like yeah we didn't really do that
everybody knew everybody back then
everybody was poor like we got it if it
was like a little kid stealing [ __ ] we
wouldn't like confront them because that
would be [ __ ] up
so you know but whatever happened
um ken and trina
found out
that
their child their four-year-old daughter
had been accused of stealing candy from
this general store
so
basically what happens uh there was a
clerk that worked there too called
evelyn sumi
she was at the back of the store
and this was like slightly after she
said she didn't confront anybody she was
basically like i've seen reports that
said
you know we confronted the kid and said
hey you know put that back you didn't
pay for it
or you know i've seen reports that said
you know hey you shouldn't do that but
you can keep it
i don't really know which is true
uh but there wasn't any big kind of
thing the kid was four
uh no one was concerned they just
thought it was a misunderstanding so
it's kind of like they're not gonna be
like oh my god you're going to jail
you're four you know what i mean it
wasn't anything like that but
trina
the wife
quote unquote who was at this stage how
old would she have been in 1980 she was
older than 14 at this point um i think
she was maybe 18 at this point
what are you doing poke
what has she got oh she's got my plastic
i got plastic bags over there with like
makeup in it that i was gonna sell oh
right well
yeah everybody's wondering where your
wigs are we're like we're almost in
we're almost two hours in and we're we
haven't had any wigs we still got a lot
of material to go through
well we're not really we're almost we're
almost almost halfway okay it's all
right it's gonna be here in a minute i'm
getting revved up everybody says hail
pookie yeah
oh she was just like [ __ ] this i'm bored
[Laughter]
yeah so i'm getting hungry
well don't get ahead of yourself yeah
yeah yeah
don't get ahead of yourself man i made
some damn [ __ ]
chicken paprika is there some of that
left it's frozen i froze it oh you froze
that yeah there's a lot left over
but i froze it because man i didn't want
to eat that [ __ ] [ __ ] three days in a
row but now i want it
we'll get a thought out then no all
right frozen well what are we gonna eat
and make something else okay
i don't know
whatever you're doing whatever [ __ ] i
can make
okay no more tacos
i'm kind of oh patty melted sound good
so so yeah so one of those
ends up happening whether this kid
actually stole candy whether somebody
like confronted her about it like i said
she was four i'm sure nobody like made a
huge deal about it but whatever the
case was
trina who at this point was probably 18
19 years old i kind of feel like
she comes barging into the store like
karen on steroids karen zilla she comes
into the store
and
uh with ken mcelroy behind her
and they're basically like uh
confronting the family why would you
don't accuse my kid
of stealing
candy from you
now the clerk at the store evelyn she
tried to kind of like tell them what had
gone on nobody accused your kids of
stealing anything it's like it was just
a big misunderstanding
but at this point trina who like i said
has been with this [ __ ] for
several years at this point is probably
like completely
brainwashed i kind of feel like um
she says
allegedly and i quote uh why would my
[ __ ] daughter lie she says
now at this point uh you know they're in
there ranting and raving ken doesn't say
anything i kind of feel like this is
mostly trina's thing she's screaming at
them uh you know don't accuse my
daughter stealing blah blah blah
they ended up leaving without doing
anything however
uh
ken was not gonna let this slight
against his family name
uh pass
so basically he decided that he was
going to call out this whole entire
[ __ ]
um
vendetta
against the bowen camp family that owned
this general store in skidmore [ __ ]
missouri
so
they leave but then when bo bowen camp
the older guy that owned the the um that
owned the general store
um he closed up that night
and he said that ken was out there
sitting on the in his truck like outside
the store like waiting for him looking
at him
um so you know
bo is like man [ __ ] this him and his
wife lois just went home they didn't
want to get into it
but he said that over the next few
nights ken kept showing up at their
house
sitting in front of their house in his
truck
staring at them
you know what i mean yeah um
so it was this whole thing
uh and he would get out of the truck he
would fire his shotgun
into the trees
um and he would just do all this [ __ ] to
like intimidate them
now
this went on for a little while
until one night in july
when beau
was sitting out behind um you know his
general store had like this kind of
loading dock in the back and if you seem
like there's a video on youtube if you
look it up if you look up um kenrex
mcelroy you'll probably find it
but there's a dude that went there in
late 2020 so you can see what the town
looks like nowadays and the um
the back loading dock still looks pretty
much the same as it looked back in 1981
so you can kind of get an idea so it's
kind of like it was almost kind of like
this wooden just patio or porch or
something like that
so beau is back there
sitting on the back loading dock of the
store
he was waiting for like a repair man to
show up
uh and he was just sitting back there
doing whatever
and ken walks up to him
and uh
[ __ ] shoots him
in the neck
three inches from his head with a
shotgun like she shot him like right
right there
uh he did live thankfully um even though
you know it [ __ ] his neck you gotta
make a movie about this [ __ ]
um they did they did yeah they did um it
was called
uh what was it called
in broad daylight i think brian dennehy
was in it
yeah they did make a movie about it
but yeah so he basically walks up and
shoots the dude in the neck
um the dude lives
now at this point
uh richard stratton who was a missouri
state highway patrol trooper
uh shows up
and he was kind of like all right i'm
gonna like i'm gonna arrest this
[ __ ] so he goes and finds his
ass and arrested him on attempted murder
this time
now he puts ken so he did actually get
arrested
for shooting the dude
in the neck in
you know
and he'd been stalking him for all this
time so they did actually arrest him on
it
so they put him in jail but he was only
in there for a night and then he posted
bond
the next day
he basically
was going around he had like a rifle
with a [ __ ] bayonet on the end
and he's like going around town he goes
to his favorite bar in town which was
the dng tavern
and he's basically like man i'm gonna
yeah i shot that dude i gotta with it
i'm gonna finish the job he kept saying
so not only
is he go around just being like a giant
[ __ ] gaping douche but he's also like
bragging about it
about how he can just get away with
anything right
so people in the town are just kind of
like you know what why is this
[ __ ] still walking around free
he shot
bobo encamped this elderly gentleman
who's run this general store everybody
knew him everybody liked him it's like
he just walked up and shot the dude and
he's still running around loose
why is he not in jail why was he only in
jail for one night for this
now he ends up
going to a trial for this
but i mean
it would be a while and in the interim
between him between the shooting and
between him going to trial
um
he did his regular like intimidation
tactics he was like basically sitting
outside the bowen camp's house um and
outside the house of evelyn sumi who was
the clerk that lived a store she lived
like across the street from them and he
would like sit out there with his
[ __ ] truck
and just like sit there stare at them
like all night long like shoot guns off
[ __ ] like that
it got to a point where he was doing it
so often that neither family like they
couldn't get they had this like sleep
and shifts and [ __ ] because they weren't
sure
what the [ __ ] he was gonna do like
everybody had to like keep an eye on
what he was doing out there they didn't
want to they
i think she wants to go outside oh pokey
does she ever close on no do you want to
go in the closet
there's nothing in there
i know it's boring
she's like that i thought that wasn't
bad
no no she's crazy
[Laughter]
she thought the closet was outside
but yeah so um so yeah so it was kind of
like this whole situation where he was
just for months and months and months at
a time he was just like sitting outside
your house
and
you know randomly like shooting into
your house and whatnot so you weren't
really sure you couldn't go outside to
like you know do your yard and [ __ ] like
that because you didn't know like what
the [ __ ] he was gonna do
so
the whole bow and camp family were like
kind of living in fear of this
[ __ ] because they didn't know
you know if he was gonna like [ __ ]
shoot them randomly or whatever he was
also
another thing ken would do
was that
he would give
uh
local kids money
to
give him information
about who was where in the town like
where's this mother where's this
[ __ ] right now where's the
[ __ ] right now it's like they
were little kids they didn't know any
better
um so at this point like the bowen camp
family who owned the general store they
were like well we need to do that [ __ ]
too
so what they do they they kind of
developed this whole code system
where
they would kind of like
they had a thing where if they had
one of their kids or like one of the
approved kids that they know of like
goes to like the general store and like
you know buys paper towels or something
like that it's like they knew that
everybody needs to come over there and
like see about
what's going on because that's like a
distress signal so they had like all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] worked out they had
like totally maneuver around this
[ __ ] in their whole entire lives
which like i said i can totally see why
they eventually ended up like being over
it you know what i mean
so
it's so it's kind of like they felt like
they were under surveillance like this
whole [ __ ] time
um so
as i said he was like ken's out there
mostly sitting there staring at them but
every now and then he'd fire a gun
and eventually evelyn sumi who was a
clerk at this
general store she got sick of it so she
goes to the town marshall whose name was
dave dunbar
and she's like can you please do
something about this this dude is always
here we can't go outside our house he's
oh he's just like intimidating us and so
uh dave dunbar the town marshall goes to
ken mcelroy it's like hey knock it off
at which point ken just pulled a gun on
him i was like yeah i'm just gonna
[ __ ] shoot you [ __ ] and he
totally would have because he didn't
really give a [ __ ] if it was a cop or
not
um at which point the town marshall quit
so you know what i mean this is like a
small town
so uh so yeah so at this point evelyn
goes to uh the county sheriff whose name
was roger cronk
and all the sheriff said
and i'm not sure how helpful this is he
basically said and this was
um allegedly what she
she told the media later that he had
said to her she's like i go to the
county sheriff and he says quote
if you have to shoot him
let us know and we'll come get him
before he starts stinking
that's what he said so basically what he
was saying was like somebody please
shoot him because we don't want to deal
with his stupid ass uh but just give us
a heads up on that so we can bring him
like i kind of feel like that's the
message that i got from that situation
you know what i mean yeah
almost ready for another well you got
some more in there no i got some more in
there well you can you can talk i've got
a couple you can top it up if you want
we'll wait till it worked but yeah so
that was the quote so basically the cops
were in a way washing their hands at the
situation but they were also kind of
like
you know low-key
nudge-nudge wink-wink trying to get the
townspoke hey why doesn't somebody shoot
him
we're not going to do anything about it
i kind of feel like that was what that
whole situation was
now in the summer of 1981
um
ken actually did get
a felony conviction
for shooting bo boeing camp
not attempted murder though because it
seems like the lawyer that was trying to
get him convicted
uh knew of his history and was like look
if we go for like the the bigger charge
we're not gonna get him we just want to
give him some prison time
so i'm gonna like plea it down to a
lesser sentence but at least so we'll
get some prisoner times prison time so
these people in the town can like get
some [ __ ] peace from this
[ __ ]
now so he ended up getting second degree
assault
which is basically
um assault with the intent of like
causing harm or intent of causing death
or something like that but it's like
lesser than attempted murder
so but that was kind of like all the
attorney felt like he could go for and
get a conviction
um
he did actually get a conviction so he
was right about that
uh but
the the uh sentence was
no more than two
years
so you know
kind of a double-edged sword there
so
ken
uh did not actually spend a day in jail
because of this charge though
he got out on an appeal bond
and uh he actually was free until his ex
his appeals were exhausted
and uh as i mentioned earlier he was
like not only a [ __ ]
feral psychopath but also super [ __ ]
arrogant and he thought he could get
away with everything so as soon as
even though he was convicted
um he got out on bond and he was
basically just going around the town
going man i'm going to finish that dude
off i can do whatever i want no one can
do anything about it so he's just like
being a [ __ ]
douchebag about it
so
at this point uh the townspeople of
skidmore missouri
had kind of this is this was the last
[ __ ] straw man and like i said i
can't blame them i my last brought straw
would have come a long time ago
but i get it you put up with the [ __ ] um
but at this point they had had enough
so what ended up happening
was that
like he so ken shows up at the dng
tavern his favorite bar
uh with the rifle with the bayonet and
he's just kind of like yeah i'm gonna
finish bow off or whatever or the whole
family
and
so what happened was that some witnesses
saw ken with the gun now again that was
like um you know that was a violation of
his uh you know bond you know i mean you
can't run around with the [ __ ] gun
saying you're gonna kill people
so some of the towns people reported it
um
and another thing too was that the some
of the people in town they started like
getting together and they're like okay
well if anybody's gonna be witnesses
against this [ __ ] we need to
like protect them so it's like they had
all these caravans and [ __ ] like that um
you know and we're gonna like show
support and everything
um
so they were gonna get them ready for
the hearing and everything and then the
lawyer mcfadden he gets this whole
hearing postponed
and the townspeople were just like [ __ ]
this it's like we can't it's like look
we've reported everything to the
authorities you guys aren't doing
anything so maybe maybe at this point we
need to like take [ __ ] into our own
hands and like i said at this point it's
been what like 20 [ __ ] years they put
up with this [ __ ] i can't blame
them not one bit
um so basically
all of them get together like not all of
them but a bunch of them um it's and
i've heard reports from between 30 of
them to 90 of them i don't know how many
people it was usually around 60 is what
people say but it's between 30 and 90.
so a bunch of the townsfolk they get
together at the american legion hall
in july of 1981.
now they're having a meeting
about ken and they're basically um you
know the uh the sheriff is there danny
estes they're like look what can we
legally do about this [ __ ] person
because he's just
you know
you guys aren't doing anything about it
we can't live like this we really need
to do something about it
what legal means do we have to fix the
situation
sheriff danny estes allegedly um
basically all he could come up with but
i don't know if that
honestly i don't know if he was just
saying this to be like just piss them
off even more and he's like hey yeah do
this but buy him out of here just like
do whatever i don't know if it was that
kind of situation
but he basically suggested he's like
well maybe we could start uh a
neighborhood watch at which point like
everyone is just like really really is
that like the the only situation that
you have
okay fine
so they're all there they're very angry
they're very frustrated
now the sheriff
and a couple of other cops like at this
point they leave town
now
it comes to light that ken
and his wife trina have just come into
town
uh in their chevrolet civil silverado
and they're going to be at the dng
tavern
now there's a lot of um speculation over
whether
all the people that were at the meeting
whether it was 30 people or 90 people i
don't really know it was a it was a
large chunk of the town people whether
they were at the meeting and they
decided hey we're going to kill this
[ __ ] let's go get him right now
or whether it was a spontaneous uh kind
of action i kind of lean toward the
latter just the way [ __ ] happens
but they find out from somebody
hey right now like while you guys are at
the american legion right down the
street uh ken and his wife are at the
dng tavern
and everybody at the meeting is like
let's go do something about that
so they all walk down the street
um you know like i said it's not far if
you've seen like video of the town it's
like [ __ ] it's not even a town it's
like a [ __ ] time it's a street
essentially it's a street with a bunch
of abandoned [ __ ] buildings on it
so they all
go down there there's differing accounts
of this
either
a bunch of them went in the bar
and they just kind of sat there silently
like looking at him like intimidating
him and then you know and then he left
just of his own accord
or there are some reports that say some
of the townspeople went in there and
told him to his face
you need to get out of town
whatever it was that happened i'm not
entirely sure but some of the
townspeople did go into the bar some of
them were out in the street
so ken comes out
him and his wife
they get in the silverado
and then they're sitting there in front
of the bar and he apparently like lights
a cigarette
and then apparently
a bunch of gunfire starts breaking out
um
and it ends up
that
ken
is killed
by two
gunshots to the head from two different
guns
uh allegedly some people came in there
and kind of got trina out of the car and
they dragged her into a bank so she
wouldn't be hurt
but
uh yeah so apparently like the the truck
they basically opened fire on the truck
several people
they waited an ambush for him
and it was again in the middle of the
street yeah
in broad daylight in the middle of the
afternoon that's how you would do it
though
in this environment there'd be no
there'd be no reason to do it in secrecy
if most of the town wanted that
[ __ ] dead
yeah
and like i said i don't know if they
necessarily planned this i just kind of
feel like it was a situation where they
were all at the meeting the target of
opportunity they got really mad and
they're frustrated they're like there's
nothing we can do about this [ __ ] he's
been here thank you victor wait spoiler
alert i just started in broad daylight
oh yeah yeah yeah it's good
um but yeah so i i kind of feel like
and then they were just kind of like
somebody came in and said oh he's down
at the dng
and everybody's like yeah let's go talk
to him
and then it got to a point where
everyone's just kind of like standing
around out in the street and one person
was like man [ __ ] this i'm gonna take
care of this right now and start
shooting and then other people started
shooting i kind of feel like it was a
spontaneous i don't think this was like
a planned conspiracy or anything like
that i just kind of feel like everybody
just got fed up
hey look at her she's throwing all your
makeup on the ground what are you doing
pookie what is the matter with you why
are you being such a bad girl she's such
a bad girl
so so yeah
so so everybody leg opened fire on the
truck
like i said he was killed by uh two
bullet wounds to the head
he had slumped over the uh the wheel his
foot actually went down on the
accelerator pedal
and you know made the engine rev so the
truck is sitting there and there's uh
photographs of it if you want to like
look it up on google
there's photographs of the truck with
the door open and everything and he uh
was just laying there dead
with the engine revving because his foot
was on the accelerator pedal and uh
after he got shot all the towns people i
i kind of love this all the townspeople
just were like yeah [ __ ] that guy they
all wandered off nobody called the
police nobody called an ambulance
nobody did anything everybody's just
like
bye and they just like [ __ ] took off
which like i said
you can't blame the people you can't
blame the people just saying you can
only push people so far
um you know so so there was that whole
situation
uh finally the police show up uh and
they found uh shell casings from two
separate weapons
one of which was a 22 caliber magnum
rifle the other was an eight millimeter
mauser
uh the guns
never recovered
now
honestly it's kind of like
i don't know i i kind of feel like this
is a situation where what ended up
happening later was that trina of course
even though she was very young at this
point even though
he had statutorily raped her even though
uh they had been together since she was
[ __ ] 12 years old for christ's sake
so i don't know how much in her right
mind she was but she was very defensive
of him she was very upset about it uh
and after a while
she actually sued i think she sued the
whole town and the sheriff's department
and everything like that she's trying to
sued them for six million dollars
for um
wrongful death she did like a long
wrongful death lawsuit
uh but it ended up settling out of court
for seven i believe it was seventeen
thousand six hundred dollars uh at which
point she moved to another town of
missouri remarried and normally and had
like a normal life i believe she died in
2012
of uh i think lung cancer i want to say
or some kind of cancer but yeah she um
she did some interviews later on where
she defended him and she's like oh you
know all the stuff they say about him
it's not true and he wasn't really that
much of a [ __ ] and stuff like that i
don't know i don't
you know i feel bad for her but it does
really kind of seem like
uh she maybe wasn't the best person to
ask about the situation i'm just saying
now one thing that she did say though
was that she insisted that she had seen
the person that had shot at her husband
and had killed him she said the dude's
name was dell clement
now
this dude uh for his he's passed away
now i believe he died in 2009 i want to
say i think he died of cirrhosis of the
liver
uh but he never admitted there was no
like deathbed confession or anything
like that he never admitted to being the
one that had killed uh ken mcelroy
but it's just kind of like
so you know so he denied it the whole
entire time um and he was actually kind
of like investigated but there was no
evidence there was really no evidence
against anybody
and even the fbi came in there was all
kind of this other kind of stuff but
honestly everybody in the town
even though it was only two bullets that
killed the guy i don't know how many
shots were fired
because
every account i've read of the situation
um said that it was basically like there
was a bunch of gunfire so i don't know
if it was you know if it was just coming
from those two guns or it was coming
from like other like multiple directions
and it was only just the two that shot
that that got him
um
but whatever happened
everybody that was there whether it was
30 people or 90 people or whatever
because it was a lot of people was the
middle of the day it was the middle of
the street like i said
um no one
would
cop to
killing the dude or seeing who had
killed the dude um like i said somebody
shot him nobody called an ambulance
nobody called the cops everyone just
left him in the [ __ ] truck
which
like i said it's you know when you look
at it in
out of context it seems terrible but
honestly this dude
i really i honestly really don't think
he deserved any better
and
i
i kind of got to give kudos to like the
people of skidmore missouri for just
being like just being totally
close-mouthed about it all this [ __ ]
time nobody
as far as i know
in skidmore missouri that lived there
then that still lives there now has ever
said one [ __ ] word
about what happened that day
um none of them have ever said anything
about who it was that killed him
who shot who was there nothing um
they're very very tight-lipped about it
and i don't even think it was like
i don't know it just seemed like a thing
where that was something that needed
doing
um and a couple of the townspeople did
say something like that um there was a
very famous quote that said yeah he
needed killing uh as i mentioned earlier
somebody said that he was like a
gangrenous leg that needed to be cut off
um so they just saw him as
this
you know he had been terrorizing them
for essentially like two decades at this
point
um and they were sick of it they had
tried to go the legal route they had
tried to report it they had tried to and
you know [ __ ] it have he had shot people
um you know he had not only had he
stolen he'd done statutory rape he'd
done all that kind of stuff and he kind
of like got off on it but he had shot
people and got like
and everyone knew that he had done it
and he had gotten away with it um
everybody had tried to go through the
legal channels
but it wasn't working and so at some
point they just came to they just came
to a place where they're like look you
know other people are going to get
killed he has openly said
that you know he shot bo bowen camp in
the stomach
you know at point-blank range i saw an
interview with bo poncamp and he said he
put the gun right against my stomach and
shot me
um and thankfully he lived
but he did that
and
got away with it
you know or or at least was like walking
around loose and openly said that he was
going to finish off at least you know
beau and maybe his whole entire family
so
i'm sure the townsfolk were probably
like look if the cops are going to do
anything about this
he's gonna kill an innocent family who
owns it that everybody likes that owns a
general store so we really need to take
care of the situation um so i kind of
feel like one or two people just kind of
stepped up and said yeah we're just
gonna
[ __ ] take this dude out
and
everyone's gonna be like much happier
about it
so it's kind of like that situation so
like i said trina
she did try to sue for six million
dollars she didn't you know
she ended up settling at court for 17
six uh so she didn't get all that kind
of stuff
now this is um
a case like i said it's it's pretty
popular famous it gets brought up a lot
as kind of an example of vigilante
justice um
and i kind of feel like that
gets brought up a lot in this situation
and like i said i do kind of feel like
i don't think it's great
to get
i mean you could argue that this kind of
stuff oh it's like a slippery slope
because like you know who's to decide
you know what if
you know just from a personal example
what if like a but like what if 60
people decided they didn't like me for
some reason they thought i was i don't
know who knows what a witch they thought
i was a witch or a communist or
something like that and it's like they
decided they were gonna like beat me to
death or whatever when i was like
walking down the street obviously that's
not cool like i'm sure those people
would think they were being righteous or
whatever so it's like this is a really
it's a it's a gray area
but in this situation
um
i'm gonna allow it because it really
does seem judge jenny will allow no i'm
just saying this dude i mean this is
egregious this dude seemed like a menace
a [ __ ] yeah like a menace to this
[ __ ] tiny town he had done all of
these things i know these [ __ ] have
been wanting to see it and he had not
been and the legal system had really not
been and honestly it wasn't any fault of
theirs necessarily because he was just
like you said a menace and he was
intimidating people into not testifying
against him and it was kind of like that
kind of situation and the townspeople
felt like they couldn't they didn't have
another choice you know what i'm saying
so it was kind of like that
well the thing is is that uh
this is only unusual because of the time
that it happened it was in the 80s
early 80s early 80s the thing is is that
through most of the [ __ ] world
history and even american history would
have gone like this anyway maybe much
sooner 1800s would have been a lot
quicker
because you know through
[ __ ]
almost the first hundred years of
american history there were no
professional police
yeah i mean
just uh militias and lynch mobs
and uh
people handling their business
there was laws
but there wasn't any kind of like
institutional law enforcement
you know you could show up to a town and
apply to be the sheriff the priority
have a sheriff there
and there would
he was the sheriff because he was badass
he'd hire you as a deputy
but there wasn't any kind of like formal
training on it it was
you learned it on the job
you know that's not a professional
police force really although they were
bad asses
but the thing is is that
and this has been said many times
through a lot of the books about the old
west and the old america that that you'd
read about
it's really easy to change your identity
back then
and
a lot of those law men were also bank
robbers
and [ __ ] train robbers
they they might live a [ __ ] life of
crime in one state
they might even do a little bit of time
and then they'd get out of prison
and go to another state and become a law
man
and they might have even been able to
become a law man in the state that they
were in if they if
if the cops liked them just because you
were
they didn't keep track of who was a
felon
you know what i mean
you did your time and when your time was
up you paid your debt you were just a
regular person you could even go out and
get guns and give you your guns back and
[ __ ]
so i don't even think there were any
rules against being a
ex-convict and being a policeman it's
just whether or not they liked you and i
thought you could do the job
and it's my understanding that a lot of
those dudes in law enforcement
through the first half of american
history pretty much
were also had backgrounds in crime never
they were they were boba fett basically
you're talking about boba fett
you know from star wars
they were kind of mixer of everything
so what you see happening here on the
street with this [ __ ] that was
unusual only for the 80s but
it's happening in missouri in a small
town that's really back in the 1800s
or halfway in the 1800s
and like i said you have to think too
that these townsfolk
put up with a lot of [ __ ] yeah and
this dude yeah they were before they
finally [ __ ] snapped that was heavy
tolerance
that's yeah that's what i'm saying so in
a lot of ways i'm i'm willing to give
them a lot of leeway on this because
they put up with this dude's [ __ ]
probably way longer than i will i know
way longer than i would have yeah um
like i said i probably would have made
it look like an accident um but instead
of just like shooting them abroad
daylight but
this type of dude
i just don't know
there's a small percentage of people
we've talked about this on the serial
killer shows
that i'm not sure
i don't think are redeemable you just
can't they don't realize this was
frontier justice and in certain
countries this is how it goes
and missouri at this time i feel like
this it shouldn't be widespread
obviously but somebody like this this is
a very special case i kind of feel
american law and the constitution and
everything they prefer to have what's
called a due process
all right when it comes to dispensing
justice do means a serious process
but it always wasn't it wasn't always
possible especially in frontier areas or
in territories a lot of the [ __ ] that
happened in the old west wasn't even any
happening in the united
states or in an american state it was in
a territory
you know that was disputed
um then there was weird [ __ ] that was
even happening in new york and chicago
in the 1800s that looked like frontier
justice also everybody carried guns
everybody
well in the cities and that's kind of
like the situation here too is that a
lot of these people were like farmers
yeah so a lot of them were armed because
you know you had to shoot like you know
coyotes or whatever it was it was like
on your farm or whatever so it's like a
lot of them were walking around armed it
wasn't unusual so
it wasn't like they planned to go out
and like shoot this dude down in the
street but
the opportunity presented itself and
they took it yeah i mean uh
all you got to do is go back and [ __ ]
look at old magazine ads from the 1920s
when they were selling like you know
pocket 32 automatics and stuff you know
the drawings and on the sides and the
[ __ ]
and the uh the sales logos
they were very urban and very [ __ ]
stylish and it was like you know knock
them down with a 32 and a picture of
[ __ ] you the customers shooting the
[ __ ] dude down
with the 32 you know [ __ ] all slick
in the arc deco city and [ __ ]
and it was because there were no real
professional police you had to cover
your own back
um strangely enough though it was pretty
peaceful
yeah you had crime but there just wasn't
a lot people kept each other in check
you couldn't act a fool in a civ in a
situation like that you know what i mean
everybody's carrying guns you woke up
the morning you put a gun on and go and
women all carried guns that's another
thing
people don't realize that all those
little 25 apc
purse guns and pocket guns and ladies
pistols and puff powder pit powder puff
pistols you've heard of those
yeah powder puff pistol look like a
little round yeah no powder puff and you
could squeeze it shoot 22s
everybody had a means of deterrence
in those days all the way up into the
30s really and in the 40s you'd see it
so you know
we live in an era era of [ __ ] police
institutions
you can ask yourself whether or not
they're successful or not i think in
general they're kind of a deterrents and
it's good to have them around
uh did they stop crime no
they detoured crime though
um they cleaned up the mess a lot you
need to have somebody on hand
but you got to have civilian auxiliary
support
civilians have to have to be able to
protect themselves too because cops
can't be any everywhere at once brazil's
proof of that
growing up growing up in brazil oh [ __ ]
it's just wild there
you know they don't allow anybody to
have guns so everyone's considered to be
a victim
they just [ __ ] shoot each other up
like crazy
and the cops are good [ __ ] gun
dealers that's a weird that's another
weird thing if you want a car if you
want a gun in brazil you go to the
police and the police will sell you a
gun
so institutions don't work but the cops
are doing it like well you're a good
family here you can have this
just you know
if you have to use it don't you know
make sure you hide the body or don't be
seen that kind of deal
militias and [ __ ] like that and then
they do that because
um the drug cartels get all the guns
they want they have the technology to
make designer drugs explosives
machine guns they can manufacture
anything they want ammunition
so the only people that are disarmed in
brazil are just law-abiding people
everybody else has them
saunders says if law enforcement had
done their job he wouldn't have been
killed i agree
uh he would have been there he would
have no they didn't it was the court he
would have been imprisoned you can't let
someone like him around well no well he
didn't even get arrested for some [ __ ]
even though everybody knew that he had
done it
um because he was very good at like
intimidating everyone in town and nobody
wanted the trouble
so it got to a point where he
you know not only was he like a [ __ ]
face but he also was a [ __ ] face that
thought he could get away with anything
he wanted and that it was like i said it
was kind of like a self-fulfilling
prophecy so at some point
if
as i said if somebody
in law enforcement had had the balls
to stand up to him and like actually put
him in prison for something um you know
or actually even arrest him for
something
then maybe
this wouldn't have happened one story
that i heard i don't know if this is
true or not
trina his wife she's dead now uh she
died in 2012.
um
she said
that because everyone like a lot of
people question they're like okay well
you're in your pickup truck you and him
outside the bar
it's the middle of the day and you see
between 30 and 90 people pretty much in
the street like gathering around your
truck and you know something bad's gonna
happen because she had said earlier that
some of them were in the bar and were
like looking at him and like they were
trying to drive him out or whatever so
she knew that something was going on
she said i don't know if this is true
but she said even before the shots were
fired
he was just sitting there in the truck
and
i don't know if he had a gun in the
truck or whatever you would think that
he would like being the type of dude
that he was
but he just sat there
and lit a cigarette as though he knew
what was going to happen yeah i don't
know if that's true or not and he was
just kind of like [ __ ] it i don't care
they're gonna shoot me and this is it
yeah i wanted to say to sandra though
yeah
had the cops done their jobs but then
all of a sudden you're now relying on
the police
which wasn't something you could always
do in the united states depending on
what state you were in
what town it was
what the situation i want you to go on
youtube and go look up the battle of
athens
battle of athens tennessee
and we're going to do a show on the
battle of athens wednesday maybe we'll
see
well she doesn't know
in the battle of athens
the police were definitely the bad guys
definitely they were an organized crime
syndicate
that was um
they had a kind of like a crime boss
um who ran them and they basically
robbed the town blind and just
terrorized the town
and some american soldiers had come back
from world war ii
and tried to vote these guys out of
office but they kept [ __ ] stuff in
the ballots and they're like this isn't
democracy this isn't the democracy we
fought
you know [ __ ] fascism for these
[ __ ] are criminals and they
took up arms against the police and
defeated them
and uh the feds got they asked for the
federal help and the fbi just told them
to [ __ ] off they weren't interested
so um no nobody was charged i think a
couple people were killed um
nobody was charged for it though and
then the insurrectionist is what they
call them ended up when they got those
ballot boxes free turned out that they
they'd wanted a landslide the entire
town had voted for them
and they ended up becoming the new town
um government and they uh they were in
there for like a long long time all the
way into the 50s and the 60s they were
running that town
and they were they were they were good
dudes you know
so
just because they're got badges and they
had uniforms it didn't necessarily what
are you doing your hair's so pretty yeah
no my hair
here in the united states that didn't
mean especially in the olden days that
didn't mean anything those dudes could
have been criminals too
we we
america had
some of these towns even some of these
big cities were extremely corrupt
detroit super corrupt
um
so
you know i don't know how
europeans tend to [ __ ] be seem to not
really have a good grasp on corruption
at least in the united states
america the united states at one time
was worse than argentina
you know what i mean
in terms of corruption back in the 20s
worse than argentina worse than brazil
not as bad as russia but
close
you know
not to say that america's a bad country
it's just that
there were certain places that were very
bad
well it's a big place big yeah um and
not it's like a federal system each
night everywhere is the same yeah it's a
federal system and each state is its own
country and those towns have their own
government governments in them and
[ __ ] you could get some real [ __ ] bags
elected into power
you know so
the
authorities
you might not always be able to trust
them here
well and like i said i kind of feel like
in this case like i said this is a very
and i think the reason that this case
still resonates with a lot of people
this many years later happened back in
1981
is that because this was
um a catastrophic failure
of
the justice system this dude was
as i said essentially able to run
roughshod over the people of this tiny
little town just because he was willing
to be a giant [ __ ] [ __ ]
and intimidate people
uh and threaten people into not um
testifying against him and to not like
bringing charges against him so the fact
that he was willing to do that and got
away with it for so long
um
just in a way it kind of like encouraged
it
because the longer he got away with
stuff
um the more confident he got so it was
just kind of like this [ __ ] up
feedback loop
of
him being like oh i can do whatever i
want to and then he would get off with
stuff because he was like intimidating
people into like silence and then he
would get off with that and then so he
he almost kind of i feel like he started
to feel like he was um
invincible
uh and to a certain extent he was for a
long time even though he got convicted
on the one charge i mean they still were
like oh he's out on bond and they let
him run around loose
um you know and at that point the
townspeople it had been like 20 years
something like that this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is running around doing
whatever the [ __ ] he wants to yeah and
there's only like four or 500 i'm
they're [ __ ] sick of it
it's just this one dude and he's [ __ ]
up everything you can't even live a
normal life because this [ __ ] is just
like running around doing whatever the
[ __ ] he does
and
i can't really blame the people for
being like let's just [ __ ] yeah put
him down yeah just put him down it was
it corruption had something to do with
it it had to
he was doing something for somebody who
had more control over that town
maybe although like i said this was a
tiny i mean if you see the town nowadays
and from what i've heard it didn't look
all that much better in 1981 it doesn't
even i don't even know if i'd call it a
town he had money though is it very
mysterious
he did but he had money from like
criminal [ __ ] well where do you think
that's what do you think i'm talking
about yeah that's what i'm saying i
guarantee you he was working for
somebody who had who was an elected
official over that town
yeah it could have been money it could
be and that's where his prof that's
where his protection was coming from
that's why it's why they didn't [ __ ]
scoop him up and get rid of him earlier
he was working for somebody who was
elected
in that town because like you said you'd
think that somebody like this
after i mean i don't know
it wouldn't even be 20 years you'd think
that after a few years of him like
causing this kind of like
ruckus
in a town as small as this
you'd think that somebody would have
accidentally
bumped him off like just knocked him off
a bridge or like run him off the road or
or shot him in a hunting accident or
something i got a i got a feeling he was
a henchman for the mayor
and he was [ __ ] selling drugs and
doing [ __ ] in other other towns that had
a bigger market and he was running like
a run around like a fool and then the
money that he was getting he was
dividing it with the mayor and the mayor
was using it to run for office that kind
of [ __ ] i'm laughing at victor can you
describe the ruckus sir yeah
some kind of [ __ ] corruption with
elected officials i mean granters can
chime man he knows how that [ __ ] works i
bet you he'll agree with me that he had
to have had some kind of political
protection
or he'd have been long gone
i mean it must have been like i said
this is pretty like small time because
this is a tiny tiny [ __ ] which makes
it even more probable but it's probably
yeah in this case
i kind of feel like you know people that
have these big grand conspiracy theories
about like you know bigger cities were
like hundreds of people involved that's
like less likely but
a town as small as this one easy to get
control and influence
yeah where a lot of people have been
there for generations everybody knows
everybody um i do kind of feel like
maybe maybe there was someone there like
protecting his ass because otherwise
like i said somebody would have [ __ ]
bumped him off like way earlier see that
money he had for protection that's a
giveaway
didn't really say what he was doing to
make this money yeah other than like
crime he was just well sometimes yes
it's going to be crime yeah he's he's
doing crime for an elected official
probably selling drugs something like
that
he never got busted for that he usually
got busted for [ __ ] like he was the
henchman for cattle wrestling yeah
stealing gas
um stealing antiques he was kind of big
on that he got busted for that for some
reason he was worth something to
somebody who was powerful and elected
there and they were protecting him
tammy says have any of his siblings
spoke out about this i don't think so
like not that i know of unless it's been
on some of the documentaries
i don't think i've ever seen any of his
siblings of which there are 15 in case
you guys are not uh you guys weren't
here earlier
um i don't really feel like if i don't
know i haven't seen any of them talk
about it maybe they have
but
i don't know i
if this dude with my brother
i don't think i'd be too sad about it to
be honest with you i'm gonna i know i'm
kind of cold-blooded and everything but
people like this
no nobody needs you on this [ __ ]
nobody give away
[Laughter]
dead giveaway yeah that was such a good
song yeah what is uh beowulf says what
does btk think of ken rex's shenanigans
i'm not worried about b i kind of feel
like btk would probably like this dude
yeah
well you know
man's got to do stuff and it's boring in
a town he's running around you know
he wasn't minister society i wouldn't
tolerate it he needed to go to church
you know could have got him right with
the lord he'd be all right he could be
all right i could have helped him like
you were like you were btk like you were
right with the lord
i'd have to see his grass
[Laughter]
how long his grass was if his grass is
above three and three quarter inches i'd
have to decide you know
or if his dog was barking too loudly i
don't think he had a dog i don't think
he
he did the right thing and was getting
rid of other people's dogs there's too
many dogs
they're [ __ ] on things and they're
biting people and they're interfering
with federal officers delivering mail
so you know it's the right thing to do
get rid of dog i got rid of many dogs
he did dogs are a nuisance civilized
people shouldn't have dogs
that sounds like some [ __ ] beats oh yeah
sure yeah
i don't know i kind of feel like maybe i
don't know i i kind of feel like maybe
these two dudes would have hung out but
maybe not because i kind of feel like
maybe ken was a little too low-brow
yeah
btk had uh grander ambitions
i feel like he thought like of simple
man you know simple man ken thought a
lot of himself too but he was um still a
dim bulb
in a lot of ways a simple man yeah
i could have turned him into something
you know but it might have been too late
what could you have turned him into
dennis could have sent him to college
[Music]
my instruction i could i could have
turned him into a into an international
baccalaureate and
he was you know because even just a
small
even a small fraction of my intelligence
were to rub off on him then yeah he
would have been very successful
you're so smart dennis of course
everybody knows
[Laughter]
oh my god raise him like my child
didn't have a son you know
should have had a son instead i was
stuck with a daughter
which that's okay you know girls are
themselves some guys have daughters you
know it's all right girls of the world
wow
no one wants that well you know
[Laughter]
you marry them off
used to be they'd pay you but
you know what you know what is
frightening about your btk impression
is that that's totally
what that dude would say yeah yeah
i don't know if i should be scared of
that
if you're going to kill me one day
no you just put yourself in that it's
like a it's like flipping a channel you
go you put yourself in that i'm going
into the serial killer mindset right now
yeah yeah
but like what if it what if it comes to
a point with like you know uh you know
with a kind of um you know jekyll and
hyde situation where you can't control
the turnover
what if what on his channel yeah what if
you get stuck on the btk channel and
then you're like just like btk like what
if you're dennis all the time no see the
problem is that when you flip on over to
dennis i'm gonna have to like escape
it's not it's not broadband it's
narrowband you're talking about you shut
off you have to shut off a lot of other
functions and it's kind of like
it's kind of like it's kind of like
dumbing yourself down
you have to become extremely mundane and
super you know what i mean extremely my
day
well you know
because he was actually just like
kind of like an extreme version of
[ __ ]
middle america in a way but an evil
version of it but he had the he had the
he wanted to appear
to be normal in every way
so you have to [ __ ]
have extremely [ __ ]
mundane values you know
yeah well that's the thing and that's
why oh thank you david june he says tom
i just got bad news have elvis pet me up
please you have to put the elvis wig on
before how much is he paying me
[Laughter]
like you come on your horror put the
[ __ ] [ __ ] on
no well i'm just saying that
all i was saying there you go let's say
one thing that's much better
that um
dennis guy that you're talking about
i don't like it i don't like him not one
bit none of us like him either really
like to say
[ __ ] couldn't get laid in a
two-bit whorehouse
not looking the way he did
wait he's abusing women
you know no that's not how you do it
you got to show a woman your heart
you know
like i did back in a date it's got to be
tender
love me tender
love me true
[Music]
never let me go
like can i just say if you get stuck in
a mode can you get stuck in this mode i
like this i do what i want to do
never let a woman don't tell you don't
get stuck in btk mode though
it should just flow normally
oh my god
flo no i think i got a uh i got this uh
appointment i have to make with uh
president nixon
[Laughter]
i'll be seeing him next week y'all gonna
eat some m m's i'm gonna eat all that
[ __ ] eminem eat all his m m's i
heard about him he can buy more m ms
he's the [ __ ] president he's the
president but i'm gonna show him that
i'm the king
a king a president has to be elected the
king is actually chosen
he's chosen by
by destiny
sometimes he has to pull a sword out of
a stone sometimes he has to slay a
dragon sometimes he has to woo of a
maiden from another country to become a
king but either way i'm the king and i'm
the king of rock and roll
everybody knows it
[Laughter]
they call me the king even though
secretly i know i'm not the king
true king is roy orbison
fine figure of a man
i agree fine figure of a man
okay
that's all i'm gonna say i'm not a
trained monkey here
yeah but i never know when you're going
to stop talking i'm not talking i'm i'm
okay i'm orientating
i'm orientating
we only say that in tupelo mississippi
maybe you should give me another drink
boy it's time to end the show jenny i
don't think it is
we're not even at three hours
it's not even three hours i told you
this is gonna be too short i told you no
no no it's fine three hours is [ __ ]
fine
i have to cook with something to eat
after this can i have one more drink
though yeah i'll make you one of the
shows though
oh you suck see i see i understand that
i understand what she's trying to do
she's trying to drink in front of the
camera and get me to ham up for the next
[ __ ] hour it's not gonna happen jenny
why
i'm having fun though
it's friday night
i'm getting started i'm hungry
okay i'm hungry i'm hungry and i have to
cook
i have to cook a patty milk i'm gonna
make some fool's gold i got a whole can
i got a whole jar of peanut butter
and a big old french bread wait you're
gonna put peanut butter on
a jar the
peanut butter on top of [ __ ] french
bread with a whole jar of jelly
picture says we can do four more hours
of sidetracks
i'm sure that'll probably happen
on wednesday they just want me to beat
the elvis
everybody likes when you're elvis
everybody loves elvis come on yeah but
yeah i you know it's kind of like that
whole thing this is kind of like the
whole [ __ ] i don't know man this dude
i don't know i was watching the [ __ ]
buzzfeed unsolved about this
and they they came to the conclusion
their conclusion was essentially
[ __ ] this guy yeah [ __ ] this guy
so as soon as they heard about all the
[ __ ] that he was doing they're like yeah
[ __ ] this guy like i don't blame all the
people and honestly i have to say
um
i don't know what is it because it's
many years later but all the people in
skidmore missouri
that every single one of them has like
kept their mouth shut all of this time
no one has said anything no one's
written a book about it hey it was me
nobody's nobody
it's just they've just totally locked
down and i
respect that
the ones that did it are probably dead
by now
they probably are but um this is
missouri [ __ ] extreme situation um
justice served
it was missouri justice missouri
missouri and like i said they put up
with a lot from this [ __ ] before
finally it wasn't just kind of like oh
this dude cut me off in traffic i'm
gonna shoot him in the face it wasn't
that situation because i know that
happens
this dude
got away with [ __ ] for 20 years like
serious [ __ ] rape assault theft
you know and he shot a couple people
and he got away with it
the justice system failed them so
i get it i get that the talents people
were just kind of like yeah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] we're not gonna like take this
anymore i get it
we don't know who did it man it might
have been cops
although like i said i don't know if any
cops were left in town because they left
but
i don't know
it doesn't really matter no that's yeah
it doesn't matter like who it was that's
all nobody's talking yeah and honestly i
hope they don't i hope we never know it
might have been cops if the cops had
left town if that's the official story
then that means that they had an alibi
my favorite thing about this story is
that
um
after everybody like shot at him and he
just died in his [ __ ] truck
and they didn't even bother they didn't
turn the truck off they just let it run
yeah nobody called the cops nobody
called the ambulance they just like went
home
yeah they're like the cops found him in
there later yep yeah they're like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yeah we're just gonna leave
him there in the middle of the [ __ ]
street yeah and it's like
yeah no witnesses no i like that and
honestly if it was me
that i'm kind of an [ __ ] but honestly
if it was me i would have liked him to
suffer more
uh they were just trying to get rid of
the problem but they were just trying to
they were being practical about it they
they weren't as sadistic as i am so
because i would have like i said i would
have wanted the dude to suffer but they
were just kind of like jenny's eating
i'm uh yeah i am kind of i admit that
[Laughter]
victor says what if he shot himself to
frame the townspeople and they're too
embarrassed to admit it
that's funny i had never thought of that
scenario but holy crap well i mean i
think the car was filled up with bullet
holes wouldn't it
yeah but still even if that had happened
it was like well at least he's dead so
like i said win-win nobody cares there's
multiple people and they mother god [ __ ]
that dude i mean just pro tip just for
everybody out there don't live the kind
of life where a whole entire town of
people just wants to shoot you down like
a dog yeah and not call the cops or an
ambulance on you for anything um
you know probably best to not be that
person yeah just saying
uh all right so tom's getting all antsy
yeah what's gonna be the next show do
you have do you know yet uh no i won't
know until
sunday because that's when the poll
closes i don't even remember what i put
in the poll okay to be honest with you
um the polls been up since yesterday if
you're on our patreon uh if you're not
on our patreon then you can actually
vote on
the topics that we talk about on the
friday night shows and you can also talk
about uh or vote on the topics that are
the movie that we talked about on the
friday movie respective also so you know
if you're not a patron you might want to
go do that because it's super fun but
yeah this was the one that won last week
so we talked about it um you know so
yeah it's friday night
it's quarter to nine
at least in florida
tom's already like packing up his [ __ ]
yeah he's gonna go to make some he's
gonna go maybe yeah i'm gonna
make some paddy knights yeah i gotta
dice onions and [ __ ] he's got a day so
i got him
all right i've been working all day too
i know i did not only did i do this shoe
i also recorded three videos today i
gotta work drunk though okay go ahead
and shut it down jenny gotta go all
right so we're shutting down we will see
you guys on sunday afternoon talking
about whatever movie that we end up
watching whatever this weekend
uh you know so thanks everybody for
dropping by hanging out with us talking
about true crime we will see you guys on
sunday afternoon
bye